It's been three years since he texts
back.
We are live right now and our brother
Joey,
Coco Diaz is in Chicago tonight.
If you are lucky to get tickets to his
show.
Adzenys in Rosemont,
Illinois.
Not Technically Chicago.
Right.
How far away is 20 minutes.
Twenty minutes just outside.
That's where Joe.
He is.
And he's a,
he's filming tonight for CSO.
CSO is some.
Yeah,
exactly.
Some new thing that uh,
Doug Stan hope has a special on seeso
now.
Joey has a special on Seeso and
apparently it's like NBC is doing
something.
Some something that NBC is doing.
Well.
Netflix is giving apparently $40 million
to Chris rock.
So what did you hear that?
But $40 million dollars for two
specials.
Jesus.
That's fucking insane.
That's $20.
Million special.
Um,
that's a record I should say they're
going to do a bidding war with hbo
apparently for like a wow.
It makes me.
I went up to $30 million and then flicks
that.
Fuck you.
Here's 40.
Holy Shit.
Netflix is balling.
Yeah.
But now I feel jipped Netflix is out of
control right now.
But.
So as HBO,
I've been watching westworld.
You Watch westworld on Hbo?
Yeah,
it is good.
I've heard about it,
but I thought it was like on CBS or
something.
Yeah,
it's good.
Yeah.
That's where they go into that weird,
uh,
like a fake world and yes.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's based on that 1973 movie with a
Yule Brenner.
Westworld.
Good old you'll.
Yeah.
Which was basically the same kind of
movie.
It was basically the same as the show.
How many times I can say basically in
the first five minutes.
Uh,
but what it was is,
uh,
it's,
you know,
so people can go and have like a fantasy
and live in the wild west,
but obviously the robots don't play and
they start malfunctioning.
And that's where I'm in episode two.
It should start to kind of like a cowboy
logan's run logan's run.
Why don't even remember that?
Really?
Don't remember Logan's run,
barely.
Remember.
I'm trying to remember when I was a kid,
what did was logan's run?
Was it a series or it was a series.
I think it was a moving then it became a
series.
Yeah,
there it is.
Oh Wow.
I remember the poster.
Welcome to the 23rd century.
Isn't that weird?
That is weird.
It's so weird what they thought we were
going to be living life like.
Do you remember space?
Nineteen 99.
I remember.
Everything was.
I remember when I was break dancing in
1994.
There was a move called the 1990 where
you jumped on.
You remember that movie?
You jumped on one hand,
you flipped up upside down on one hand
and spun the move that I'm Cuba gooding
Jr.
Did in go back.
Go back to those pictures.
Go back to the first one you went to.
Look at that.
They got one thing right?
People are going to be wearing pre
rippeD pants like assholes and girls are
going to be showing their vaginas.
Yeah.
They got both of those things right.
And that hairstyles back.
So both harris tazobactam chicks are
wearinG hairstyles like that too.
So what did the,
what was the move the 1900,
1990 and it was good stuff.
Is that real cost play,
but I could keep causing girl.
Yeah,
whatever you're doing for.
See,
I'm so happy that girls still dress like
that.
All this crazy talk of women,
you know,
like not,
not dressing sexy or a luring like that
is just disturbing to me.
Russell peters.
I don't,
I don't want that to change.
I mean,
you know,
it depends on when and where they're
doing it.
Right?
No.
Do it whenever you want.
Given the green light office buildings,
everything.
The office buildinGs will be great fun.
I remember going into office buildings
is getting a hard on looking at the
secretaries and the yields full heart
on.
It was in my early twenties,
late teens.
You know,
you got a madman.
He was a lunatic with a different kind
of guy.
Knocking shit over with my car.
He didn't grab any pussy though.
Did you?
I was not a pussy grabber.
I'm not either.
I have no.
I don't even know how you'd grab a pussy
without actually fingering it.
Yeah.
Like how do you grab it on the outside?
that's the benefit of having those
little hands,
little hands.
Congrats.
you could just fully grab a lunch,
like one of those,
uh,
like folder holder things that used to
paperclips.
Oh,
I know those ones.
Clamps,
clamp plants,
steel donald,
clamp running for president.
CLamp and pinch.
There's a fucking hilarious,
a meme that I saw that somebody put
online.
It's so funny.
It shows different presidential quotes
throughout history.
Like the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself.
Franklin delano roosevelt ask not what
your country can do for you,
but ask what you can do for your
country.
China of counTry.
John f kennedy grabbed them by the
pussy.
Donald trump.
This is where we are.
This is really where we are.
We,
we turned reality into reality.
Young.
Do you think that that's what started
it,
all that like reality tv,
like from survivor on exposing the world
to instead of,
instead of two people that we've created
like magnum pi or,
you know,
fill in the blank,
they gave us,
they gave us things that we used to have
things to strive to want to be.
Yes.
Um,
and then they took it down to the lowest
common denominator made.
It made us go,
oh,
thank god they took away all that.
Now we can just be normal again.
We can,
we can be hopeless.
Yeah.
They brought it down a snuggie.
You know,
they went from,
it went from people that you could never
guys like macgyver.
Yeah.
Gets out of every situation.
But that's confusing too though,
right?
Because People start thinking that they
can be macgyver or that they can get
your brain moving.
It kind of gives a little jog.
It makes you think sideways,
you know,
and it gives you the opportunity to
think laterally.
but when you've got a dummy just saying
things that you want to hear,
you go,
oh,
okay.
I can turn it off now guys.
That's the one thing that confuses me
the most about Donald Trump.
I didn't know there were that many
assholes out there.
Like I kind of knew,
but I didn't know they were going to
organize it.
It was,
it's weird to me that,
you know,
when you meet people that you're
getting,
you thought were levelheaded thinking
people.
Is that eric?
Be like eric b and rakim.
Nice.
Everybody.
Everybody's actually living at my house
in vegas right now.
Shut the fuck up.
Really?
Yeah.
Damn dude.
You know I keep it hip hop son.
Do you do?
Yeah,
you do.
What about rakim?
Rakim is not living in the house.
No,
no,
they're,
they're a secret.
I think they may be getting back
together secretly.
He just keeps saying I don't,
I can't say that they are.
So there may be.
I mean,
will.
You're starting rumors.
That's the way to go to god.
That's the way to go.
To get that one started trying to get
everybody paid.
Oh,
I love those guys.
We were just talking about them
yesterday.
Where you.
Yeah.
We were talking about yesterday.
Was that jesse?
Jesse,
ventura,
and then red band.
But we were talking about,
uh,
eric b and rakim.
We're talking about epmd.
Yup.
I'm friends with dj scratch from apmt
from all sides of the dj of the group.
Have you noticed that?
Yeah,
well you were a dj.
that makes sense.
Yeah.
So like us being friends with comedians.
we happen to know one or two of them.
Yeah.
isn't it funny thing about being a
comic?
Like you run into another comic
somewhere and you're like,
aw,
you come here,
you were around regular people kit over
here.
We're all left brain thinkers.
We need to be together.
is that what it is?
Yeah,
that's the left brain.
that's what I've heard.
We're not real.
I don't know.
I'll give You a kick.
Somebody left side of the head is a fuck
up.
Their jokes.
I don'T know what somebody else.
Somebody sent me something that says,
uh,
it's in my,
it's on my whatever,
but it was about some sort of head
trauma can make your brain,
uh,
relate everything to a joke after.
Well,
there's a book that sam kinison,
his brother wrote,
brother sam,
and uh,
it's all about how sam.
Well,
it's all about sam,
but it's all.
A big part of it is how sam changed when
you got hit by a car.
He was a little kid and he got nailed by
a car and really fucked up and from that
point on he became this maniac,
this wild,
crazy,
reckless motherfucker.
Like before that he was like a normal
kid and bang one hard shot to the head
and all of a sudden he's like all the
crazy ranting and the sermons he used to
give when I guess when you get close to
death,
you look at it one of two ways,
right?
Yeah.
ThAt's it.
I think it's traumatic brain injury.
That's what I'm saying.
But like,
again,
your brain goes,
oh,
fuck,
well we didn't suffer through that.
Now let's just enjoy the rest of this.
That would be nice if that was,
if that made sense,
if there was a fact.
I don't know,
but I like making up my own.
I think what it is,
wikipedia damage,
I think damage to the brain,
like actual physical damage effects,
impulse control,
and it has something to do with that and
getting angry quicker.
There's,
there's a bunch of factors that come
into play that you see with football
players to.
Yup.
Um,
that,
uh,
you're,
you're hilarious after all those times
now,
right?
Maybe they are.
Maybe we need to find one right before
they become too stupid to talk.
YeS.
Ask him like,
what?
What do you find?
I mean they weren't that bright to begin
with.
So How dare you say that they can be
bright if they were big and giant and
they wanted to make money is The way to
go.
Right.
What else could it do to be a strong
man?
I don't know.
I mean you could fight strong.
Me.
You can fight if you that big because
like at 265 pounds,
that's the weight limit for mma.
There's a limit on.
This is so weird.
So weird.
Because remember emanuel yarbrough,
was he 600 pounds?
Yeah.
We'll look what happened to him.
Keith hackney,
bitch slapped coma.
It's true.
Did he break his wrist on that bitch?
Slap upside.
Weird.
Yeah.
Well once he got them down,
he was hammer fist and he was like one
of the first guys to do the hammerfest
in a fight.
I remember seeing that going,
that's a terrible punch.
It's effective.
You know what's cool about a hammer
fist,
it's like you can do this to the table
like this oak table and doesn't hurt
your hand at all,
but if you did that with your knuckles,
you'd be like,
ah,
yeah,
but it's weird that we punched with our
knuckles.
Well,
if know we just associate this soft
padded part is not going to hurt you.
Exactly.
It fucking hurts a lot.
Like hammer fists are very effective.
Have you hammer fisted anybody?
No.
It never hammer fist anybody.
Not that I can remember.
We went into fisting real quick.
When you spinning back fist somebody,
there's two ways to do it.
You could do it with the actual back of
the hand that hurts.
Like if you hit someone's very tender
there.
Yeah.
If you hit someone's chin with the very
back of your hand,
you could fuck your and you could break
your hand for sure.
But the right way to do a spinning back
fist is with the hand down with the palm
of the hand facing down with the fist.
So in that way you are hammerfest
summit.
You really,
it's really offended him more than a
spinning back fist.
That's the way to do it,
right?
I've never done a spinning back fist.
No,
no.
It's a brutal move.
And you got a really time.
That one right?
Yeah.
You do.
You gotta you gotta be you gotta.
Be very confident knowing that you're
turning your back on the guy real quick.
It's weird how the different ways people
figured out how to fuck people up.
I was watching a street fight today
between these two checks here for.
No,
no,
no.
It was on.
It was on instagram.
Somebody said.
Was it the one where the girl said,
kicked my ass,
bitch.
Kick my ass.
You said you were gonna kick my ass.
Kicked my ass.
Bitch.
I two white girls sounded really good to
black girls listened because my wife was
there.
I just watched two,
a blonde girl and she,
her head,
she even know.
Yeah,
it uh,
she throws her to the ground.
She kinda like kinda curves are a little
bit too.
Just beats the fuck out of her.
And she got attacked.
She got attacked.
She totally turned around,
beat that girl's ass,
and she kept chasing her and that girl
kept talking shit.
Yes.
While I was getting the fuck out,
I'm like,
well,
you know,
if he hit her on the jaw,
maybe she'd go to sleep and wouldn't
have to hear her talk anymore.
But the girl.
My point was when she had her down,
she's hammerfest and people know that's
a legit move now.
Like mma has changed street fighting
forever.
It really has.
People know,
they know what to do now,
you know,
and you could see like,
especially with kids,
there's a ton of videos of trained kids
who actually know how to fight and they
get by someone who doesn't know how to
fight and they wind up arm barnum or
getting him in a month.
It's like the kid that did that,
a cat williams.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
Well it was a wrestler.
Yeah,
it was 17.
I thought he was only 15,
15,
whatever it was.
He was a teenager.
Yes.
He got and he got him in a nice seat,
stretched them out and everything.
He got his back and just stretched.
What the fuck is wrong with katt
williams?
I don't know,
man.
He's one of us.
What's he doing?
I don't know.
He's one of us,
but he's also one of those guys.
It seems like.
Who's,
uh,
who's hitting that pipe every now and
then?
I don't know.
I can't confirm nor deny those
allegations.
Definitely some stimulants involved.
There's something going on.
Something's gone awry.
I'm fascinated by him because I think
he's one of the best comics alive in
bursts,
like in moments,
but then he'll have these horrible
wretched shows where there's class
action lawsuits or money back and he
ends up leaving,
but then he gets it back together and
have some amazing stories.
Like he'll put together a special and
have amazing stories based on all the
fucked up shit he did.
It's almost like he does it on purpose.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
But I don't think he does,
but it seems like he could read,
he could write the ship.
Like he just like,
fuck it.
I'm staring into the wind steer steers
into the wind and that he's like,
all right,
that did not work out.
We gotta,
we gotta get the cat williams boat back
online.
We've got to turn this around as an
iceberg coming and he figures out how to
right the ship and then he comes back
around.
But man,
when he's on he's fucking funny because
he's fearless.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Fearless.
Yeah,
he definitely does not give a fuck.
And with his hair is the something about
that conked out hair and the sweat
profusely sweat.
That'S that molly sweat.
Sweating that mtma I guess system.
did you ever see the time where him and
steve harvey,
they,
uh,
they did this thing together.
It was real weird.
It was like they were touring together.
It doesn't make any sense to me at all.
Steve harwood go on first and then kat
williams would go on second and uh,
I guess they were like talking shit
about each other leading up to the show.
So steve harvey goes on and then kat
williams spends the first 10 minutes
mocking him and it is fucking brutal and
hilarious.
Well,
I'm on,
I'm with cat on that one.
It's hard to not be that.
Steve harvey guys.
A weird dude.
I've never met him actually,
you know,
27 years in this game.
I never met steve harvey.
Well,
I met him a long time ago back when he
was essentially doing a richard pryor
impression when I met him in the
nineties.
He was doing richard pryor on stage.
I mean,
it was crazy.
Like if you didn't know,
you would think like [inaudible] this
guy like auditioning for richard pryor
movie or something.
I don't remember his standup at all
from.
It wasn't like he was doing priors
material,
what he was talking as if he was richard
pryor,
you know,
there was there the whole thing guys,
there's the,
you know,
how it is.
There's like you get influenced.
Uh,
did you ever do that?
Um,
there was no,
I mean I was always into like carlin and
stuff like that.
So I was not smart enough to copy carla.
Like I knew my intelligence level was
far lesser than carlin.
So I would,
uh,
I would just do what I did.
I caught myself on stage once sounded
exactly like richard,
jeni and I was like,
jesus.
Oh wow.
Exactly.
You went in.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean I was open miker,
but now there's,
you know,
there's a whole slew of comics that try
to sound like mitch.
Really?
Yeah.
There's a few of them out there and It
freaks me out and everyone's on their
dick and I'm like,
wait,
you know,
that's mitch,
right?
That they're doing well,
like,
okay,
can't tell me names,
but yeah.
Well hedberg had such a distinct style
that would be kind of crazy.
But you hear what the tell.
I mean in New York there's like five or
six guys that I could name right now.
Everybody at the seller has the same way
of speaking there all a towel babies.
yeah.
Yeah.
Or that shut up stupid.
You know,
it's,
everybody wants to be Keith Robinson
too,
right?
Yeah.
But It's interesting,
you know,
that's one of the reasons why everybody
went to with the uh,
what's that?
Uh,
that's,
that's a,
that's a seller thing.
What are you doing?
I get it.
What do you,
uh,
are always everything makes them,
when it does that,
when you go to the seller next time you
talked to everybody and be like,
oh my god,
that's the fucking seller talk.
I like it clicks.
It is a bit cliquey,
but he did,
but I get sucked into it when I'm there
too.
I just do it because I'm around them.
I mean,
I'm like,
I guess this is what we're doing guys.
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting how little clubs like,
uh,
like the seller just spawn.
They just take off and it becomes the
spot.
When you think about how many spots
could be the spot in New York city?
Yeah.
Does New York city like have 100 comedy
clubs or something?
Crazy?
Ton of them.
And then there's new ones opening all
the time and then there's people try
doing a nice one or class two year one
and that shit never works.
Yeah,
you need the nice grimy seller.
I mean it's just,
it is what it is.
Low ceiling.
Everybody packed in real tight and then
you get like the,
the,
a list of comics walking through there.
Yeah,
just to pr.
Isn't that funny that it's also funny
too,
that like to practice the best place to
practice is a little tiny place always.
Yeah.
You don't want to practice in front of a
room full of people and three of three,
400 people.
Have you ever thought about doing a
special in front of a tiny group of
people?
Um,
I have,
but then,
you know,
sarah did the one in front of like 12
people or something like that.
She did,
yeah.
She did one,
lIke really small audience.
It wasn't at largo.
Yeah.
How big is largo if you're one of the
small rooms at largo?
Oh really?
Yeah.
Huh.
But I mean if anybody can make that
work.
Sarah silverman.
Ken?
Yeah.
She's fucking funny.
She doesn't do enough.
She doesn't do enough and she doesn't
get the respect she deserves.
I don't think so either.
Yeah.
I mean she's,
she's not funny on a curve.
Like,
oh,
she's a funny woman.
You know,
she's,
I told her that once.
I said,
you know,
sarah,
you're one of my favorite comics,
not one of my favorite female comics,
one of my favorite comics as a human
being comic.
I saw her at the store maybe a year ago,
and she was murdering just murdering.
And I was like,
man,
sometimes I forget how good she is.
You forget how good she is,
how great her jokes are written.
And uh,
you know,
I get through this.
I go through this little phase when I
like,
now I'm back at the zero point with no
material and I've been going out every
night,
but I might.
My trick is to go and host so that way
there's not too much expectation on.
Right.
So I'd move.
Yeah.
So I can get my confidence back and then
I could see,
know the level of talent around me and
in what way everybody's thinking and uh,
you know,
then I,
then I can figure out if I want to tell
stories if I want to tell jokes,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
When do you write,
do you write in front of a computer or
do you write on.
I know physically write anything ever
really ever.
A lot of guys are like that.
They'll burdens neither.
Yeah.
We had that conversation about that.
I can't.
I feel like it's a.
Well,
first of all,
I'm too lazy.
That's the real issue.
It has nothing more to do with anything
that I don't want to sit down to write
this.
I don't even want to watch my sets.
My almost famous specialist out now.
I haven't watched it.
No,
it was good.
It was sent to me months ago and I was,
like I said on netflix.
Yeah.
When,
when did you film it?
In april and did.
How many times did you watch it?
Not once.
You didn't wAtch it all day?
Not even once.
My brother was sat in on the edits and
then my mom was watching it and my mom
was in town.
My mom's in town,
so she was watching in the living room
the other day and I walked past like,
what are you watching?
She goes,
you and then I was listening here and
they're like,
why did they keep that in?
Why that sucks.
Why would you keep that in?
Yeah.
I just watched the trailer for my
special today and I was just.
I don't like watching myself either.
Oh,
you're just coming on like in a week or
two?
October 21st in a week basically.
Yeah.
Next friday.
Twenty first I opened for you.
You just last week my special aired,
so.
Oh,
I'm like,
what?
I know I smoked a lot of pot,
but you have now we know.
We've never done a show together.
I don't think we've done the ice house.
Oh,
that's true.
I hosted that.
Yeah,
we'll do it again then.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
I like hosting.
It's fun for there.
Again,
on the 28th,
the friday,
friday the 28th.
I think I am in san jose that weekend if
I'm not mistaken.
Oh really?
San jose improv.
I love that place.
Yeah.
That fucking improv is this shit.
It's great.
But again,
I have no act so you know,
if anybody is coming out to see me,
just understand that I don't have an act
right now.
So.
Well,
you've got a little bit of an act like
how much you have zip.
Literally fucking nothing.
I haven't done one joke and I could say
it now,
but then it's over.
know how much time do you give yourself
before you started doing theaters again?
I wait till I got jokes.
Actual jokes.
I waited till I got at least 40 minutes.
So do you like just keep banging it out
and then just go,
okay,
we're good.
Start booking shit or do you get in like
a few months and you go all right and
I'm going to give myself a deadline.
Deadlines are good for us.
Yeah.
Because otherwise we're just,
you know,
just keep coasting.
That's how for me,
writing a new specialist,
very importantly to putting a special
out and then chuck in it and then
writing all new shit.
It's so important because otherwise we
all know those guys that had been around
forever doing the same material.
Oh I know some comics in Canada.
Hilarious.
They're acts are funny as hell,
but they've been doing the same act for
30 years.
That's so crazy.
And then they give me shit or new.
The last special wasn't very good.
I go,
yeah,
well you know what?
You haven't done new material in 30
years that you cannot get people to get
a little brave.
Brave on the internet.
They're a little jealous bowls.
And josh russell national,
they'll make their little facebook
statuses.
Mr.
Worldwide.
Like pit bull.
That's it.
I'm shit.
It's a fucking problem.
Was killing joe with the puns that
killed him was I was trapped in a pun
sandwiched between tony hinchcliffe on
one side of Russell Peters on the other
side.
It depends.
We're flowing like water.
Would you like to sun bread or a pun?
I had to start doing puns myself and I
rarely do parties.
I was throwing them in myself just to
keep up with these fucking guys.
So.
Well,
it's such a specific style of joke,
the pun,
you know it is it.
It takes you back to your father's.
Father's always did.
Yeah.
That's like the silly,
clever thing to say.
My father.
Or you have an uncle who had the puns.
What have you.
Yeah,
what have you,
dude,
you chose,
you tour everywhere man.
Like you were in dubai and Saudi Arabia.
Holy shit.
What is that like?
You do the show.
His men on one side.
Women on the other.
Good.
So I play over there.
Yeah,
I was asking them like why?
Like why,
why don't like and honestly the guys
would tell him and he's like normal.
It's supposed to be normal level headed.
Men telling me this and these weren't
like,
you know,
any high ups are just normal guys.
Oh [inaudible] the women,
they'll go crazy and don't want to
attack us.
So I'm like I look at you,
but dude look at them.
They're not trying to attack you.
They'll want to attack and have sex with
them in the streets.
That's what they've been brainwashed
into.
Believing that if these women aren't
separated,
they'll just come and attack you and
want that dick.
Maybe that is the case though,
when you keep them separated,
if you keep them from men all the time
when they finally get around that maybe
they just jump on tick like a hero on
the guys are a little too friendly with
each other as far as I'm concerned.
Gay stuff.
Yeah,
but I don't even think they recognize it
as homosexual because they're like,
I'm not attracted to men.
It's just get horny and they just start
jerking each other off.
I don't know that for sure,
but you know,
I could see that as as a possibility if
you're just around dudes all the time
just repressed.
Well,
I know dudes who have been in the
military who've done tours and they go
overseas to the middle east and they say
that guys,
fuck young boys all the time.
It's weiRd to me.
Well you think that that's a like a
consequence of the separation between
the men and the women?
Yeah,
I guess I don't know what it is.
It's weird to me,
but when I did the show,
I played right down the aisle.
I stood where the aisle was when I was
on stage and stood where the hail was so
that I didn't really Pick a side.
Can you turn like a sprinkler?
I kept turning like that.
Like I was just trying to water half the
lawn.
Now when you do shows lIke that,
do you ever worry about doing something
that get you in trouble?
Um,
it's not so much that I worry about
doing stuff that'll get me in trouble.
It's doing stuff that they may deem as
offensive because I know what is
offensive and then then you gotta worry
about people's sensitivities.
So I'll always ask the promoter,
lIke straight up,
I'm like,
what can't I talk about?
no,
religion dimension,
the royal family and try to keep sex to
a minimum.
I'm like,
all right.
wow.
No religion can just mock.
Mormons can make fun of mormons.
It probably could.
Yeah.
They wouldn't give a fuck.
they would again wouldn't know what a
mormon was.
They would think of as a sect really
know.
I don't know that.
I'm sure they wouldn't know what a
mormon is.
Mormons very specific to this
part of the world wasn't created here.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was created in.
Well,
they,
they took over Utah essentially.
It's interesting.
Do you perform in Utah lot?
Once or twice?
Not very often.
It's real interesting club.
It's great.
Yeah.
Well,
wiseguys in salt lake,
they have two of them now,
right?
They have a larger one.
They had the original one that I think
they opened the larger one,
the one down from the mall.
I don't remember the address but,
but um,
they have.
It's utah's interesting because you have
like these mormons but you have a lot of
like really cool people that are sick of
the mormons bullshit and they surround
him too.
But then it's marvins mean it's a wacky
cult.
Right.
It's very bizarre.
But they're really nice.
They're like some of the nicest cult
members ever.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a
tough line to walk because you're not,
I'm not sure what their deal is.
You're not sure if they're trying to
convert you,
but then I as a brown guy,
I'm like,
well,
they only just started letting us
believe their shit about 20 years ago.
Right.
Then they only let black people in like
20 years ago.
Is that what happened?
I didn't even know.
This ain't black mormons.
There's got to be like a clan of black
mormons.
Please find that jamie.
It's got to be some sort of a group
where they get together called more than
men's jesus christ.
and it'll be good.
Joe mentioned that didn't happen,
but they have a great spot like salt
lake city's got damn gorgeous.
You know,
they have the mountains there.
I just.
Nice areas.
Nice up there.
yeah.
I love Utah.
I walked a lot when I was there.
I would walk from the hotel to the gig.
Why?
Why not?
Okay.
It was nice.
Nice air.
Needed.
The exercise.
Yeah.
Salt lake city is uh,
it's,
it's just,
it's weird when you associate a place
with something like san francisco used
to be gay.
Yeah.
So like even the gaze can't afford it
anymore.
It's not Really gay anymore.
Yeah,
they out price the gaze.
they did.
They did.
I mean there's definitely some rich gay
folk out there,
but as far as like having a community of
specific people,
it's more tech tech millionaires and
shit.
It's a lot of that and a lotta.
There's a lotta and there's a lot of old
money there too,
you know,
people have just been there forever.
There's that.
But as far as like the amount that
things cost in san francisco,
that's the most obscene I've ever seen
in terms of like real estate and what it
costs to buy a house.
Yeah.
Because if you want to be in the city,
right?
Yeah.
But that's pretty much aNy city if you
want to be in it's gonna cost you a lot
more.
It will cost you a lot more.
But in west hollywooD it new york's
insanity,
but you could live in west hollywood and
it kind of makes sense.
But you know,
I rent in west hollywood.
It's hard to own in west hollywood
because I feel like everything has been
purchased by somebody and they just rent
everything out at a absorb.
Extremely high rent.
Yeah,
I guess that makes sense,
but there's stuff for sale,
but it just doesn't.
It's California so strange because of
the earthquakes.
Everything's all spread out,
like nothing stacked on top of each
other.
I mean you have downtown but downtown.
So rare.
It sounds so new.
Yeah.
Well it is now.
It's becominG new again.
Yeah,
and they're.
They're real estate downtowns.
very expensive now too.
I remember when they started doing it
about 10 years ago,
it was cheap and now you're like,
wow.
It's like almost like New York pricing.
Yeah.
They're were turning it into an actual
real city.
Johnny.
Johnny depp is selling some.
Were you telling me about that?
Johnny depp is some sound,
some preposterous chunk of real estate
there where he's got like five floors
and some gigantic.
Well,
you know he's getting divorced.
Yeah.
So he's got to him and start dumping
shit.
The kids getting fucked.
He's getting fucked.
Johnny.
Yeah.
He's going to have to give up a ton of
cash.
That dummy didn't even get a prenuptial,
or at least i got a prenup this time.
Good for you this time.
This time.
First time.
No,
but I was only married for 14 months,
so it didn't matter.
They can't fuck you if you're only
married for 14 months.
No.
Look at this.
Seven months.
Just listed his five los angeles
penthouses for 12 point seven.
Eight dollars million.
He's got five.
Which he just sold one of them.
Is it 12 point seven each or in total?
Total for all five.
Oh,
that's not too bad then.
No,
it's not stacked.
I thought it was just they are there.
I'll take the top couple floors of one
of those buildings.
Five units.
It's all him.
What is he doing?
Buying all this stuff.
It looked pretty cool.
I think you guys buy all that stuff
because the money starts flowing in and
he said,
whoa,
he's got some baller fucking houses.
Holy shiT.
Yeah.
That's some cool shit.
Wow.
That is amazing.
What a cool looking place.
Three of them are connected.
The other two I guess are separate.
Oh,
I see.
So we selling those two and the other
thing,
but the problem with apartment living is
man,
you wind up paying all that money and
then the neighbor,
right next door has a party.
Yeah.
And you listen to his bullshit.
That's probably why he bought all those.
So that way he was his own neighbor.
Yeah.
That's a good move.
But you're still an also then if you're
in downtown la one day the earth is
going to shake.
Yep.
And that building,
your end's going to be useless.
You're not gonna be able to fix that
thing.
To get a break.
There's going to be structural issues.
They're going to have to vacate the
entire thing and you're going to get
fucked out of all your hard earned cash.
All that jack sparrow money.
Well,
he's getting fucked out of it anyway.
His earth is shaking already,
but she's hooked up with elon musk.
Has she really?
Yeah.
Maybe she'll leave me alone.
Maybe she'll cut them some slack.
I understand that she was with elon
musk.
Now I'm a smarter than that.
No,
you would think that guy's a fucking
genius.
He's a.
He's a thinker.
I think he likes pussy.
Yeah.
we all liked posting while he was
dating.
He was married to some actress before
that apparently didn't have a prenuptial
with her.
Oh,
terrible billionaire and the baby elan
musk relentlessly pursued and was
infatuated with amber.
Heard sending repeated emails requesting
to meet the actress.
Okay.
I don't like the way that's phrased
because that's the work of some asshole.
Yeah.
It sounds like he wanted to grab her
pussy.
Who wrote that?
Is that a girl,
a girl or guy wrote that,
chris.
So it could be either.
Yeah.
Ryan.
I liked how you did that.
It was written by pat.
Remember?
It's pat.
You couldn't do that today.
Today.
They would call you transphobic.
Yeah,
there's every phobic now.
She's not gender binary or zs,
not gender binary.
There's a from your part of town,
university of toronto.
There's this embattled professor who's
a.
He's like standing his ground against
political correctness in,
in,
in toronto,
and the kids are going crazy to try and
get him removed.
He just refuses to use the 28 different
gender pronouns.
He refuses to let people choose what
gender pronouns they want to be called.
He's like,
no,
I'm going to call men men.
I'm going to call women women like,
this is ridiculous and this is
censorship like you're trying to change
people's behavior with the pr.
Here's the problem is that people now
with with all these free,
this new liberty,
they are just choosing to do things as
opposed to actually being a certain way.
And I saw this story about this kid
gavin something or another,
I think it's in North Carolina,
if I'm not mistaken.
And uh,
and it was born a girl,
but when you see it,
is it 14 or 15 year old?
Now he identifies as a male and when you
see it,
you're like,
oh yeah,
he's a boy lead.
There's,
there's no reason for me to not believe
that this is the right way for this
person to be.
But it should be case to case.
You know what I mean?
It shouldn't be.
He can't just blanket statement,
oh,
whatever you want to be,
you can be.
No,
fuck that you,
it has to be genuine.
You can't just do it because that's the
thing to do,
right?
And does have to be genuine,
but when you opened it up like that,
then it gives people who legitimately
feel like during the wrong gender,
it gives them the opportunity to express
themselves in a different gender.
What's fucked up is that you're born a
boy and you're a fucking boy.
Alright,
you're born a girl,
you're a girl.
But if you were born a girl and he feels
like you're a boy,
you'd never really going to be a boy,
you know?
So if I call you a boy and he'd take a
bunch of hormones and everything,
you're still not a boy,
what would it be?
Nice.
And what's probably eventually going to
happen?
There's going to be a way that they can
change your sex,
like literally change your sex.
There's going to be some way where they
interfere with your dna.
they get in there and Russell Peters
becomes russell ina.
Peter's a little,
uh,
a little,
hacking on your system there.
If you a girl,
what would you change your name to rose?
Who I get?
I think I'd still want to be rp.
Beautiful.
You'd be beautiful.
You'd be like a flower.
I'd be beautiful flower.
Russell rose pedals.
I like be two that I'd be to lift
brogan.
I've always wanted to be a to that.
I feel like they're an under appreciated
flower.
They're to be rose because rose is like
the king of the flower.
So It's a lot of pressure.
Um,
but then you don't to be orchid because
that's the more expensive work.
It's more expensive than roses.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
they're very expensive.
Really?
How do you know this?
Because my fiance loves orchids.
Oh,
but the good thing with those is you buy
one and they last for a long time.
you can keep those alive really?
How's that?
Uh,
the way they are,
you wrap them around the stick and they
just keep growing.
Oh,
okay.
So when you ask them,
are they in dirt?
Yeah.
You got them in dirt?
Okay.
So rosa is you buy them and they're in a
bush,
so they died quick.
Yeah.
It's that life support system thing they
do when they put it in water,
like kci throw some water to keep them
fresh.
We pulled,
we pulled them.
Should we pull the plug on these houses
yet?
You know what I found out recently,
we were talking about this the other day
that you can take the stem of one plant
and plant it on another plant.
I goes at this ranch and theY had
pistachio trees and the arms of the
pistachio trees are grafted onto an
avocado tree.
So that stem cell.
No,
it's not.
Just try to make a pun out it.
I betcha.
It can't all be good,
joe.
You got to spit them out so that way
they get out there and you find out if
they're good or not,
but you can't take a rose like when
someone gives you a rose has been cut.
You can't make that thing stay alive.
Kenya,
can you plan it in dirt?
No.
It needs.
It needs the roots.
It's not going to grow roots right now.
It can't.
I don't think it can grow roots.
It's over.
I think the,
the,
the top of the bud,
uh,
can,
can flourish still.
The flower,
the flower itself can do what?
It can still flourish for a little
while,
but the body is dead basically in the
stems.
Dead.
Yeah.
The stems dead.
So,
but you can't take the flour and
somebody dies like,
you know,
an increments.
It's dead from tHe,
from the cut point I would imagine.
Oh,
is that what it is?
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm assuming it'd be dead from the cut
point and then it just slowly dies.
It's way up that.
That makes sense,
right?
You can.
Yeah.
So I'm an idiot.
No,
you can regrow a rose once you cut it
off the stem for real.
I'm just not a horticulturalist.
well,
it's,
it's interesting to watch people who
know flowers,
they know what to trim and whatnot.
The trim,
they're constantly like cutting pieces
off of it.
That's why they do what they do and we
just pay them to do.
Okay.
I have nothing.
I got nothing for that.
What's that?
Use it doing it using potatoes.
Oh,
I've seen that before.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Rose stems,
you stick it in a potato and what does a
potato do?
It probably helps give it a root base,
I would imagine.
Are you.
I'll make it again.
People hear you right now in that.
Yeah,
I mean you guys can hear me right,
but they won't do that in la because
people tend to avoid potatoes and carbs,
so they do.
Now.
It's the newest thing.
Have you been on that yet?
What?
Avoiding carbs?
No,
clearly.
Look at me.
It looked like.
Avoided the fuck did I do I just fucking
like food?
I do too.
I give myself cheat days.
Yeah.
When I had,
when I was for the special ed,
hired alex,
a reason to train me.
Alex,
the guy who trained out really and hired
him for you get you on steroids.
No,
no,
he didn't.
It's famous for that.
That's what everybody thinKs he does,
but I,
I didn't see it.
He just works.
You fucking incredibly hard.
Like.
Yeah.
And I waS like,
alex,
you know,
I don't have a fight coming up.
Right?
Like literally,
I'm not exaggerating when I say this.
I would spar 12 rounds boxing and then
1212 with 32nd breaks.
Yeah.
And then after that an hour and a half
of corp comm on my god,
I'm dying and I would let it really get
home and just be in bed for the rest of
the day.
That was it.
So all that core stuff that pack out
does.
Do you think you've got all that from
him?
I would imagine so because I was just
wondering.
I was like,
I've never seen a figHter work more on
their core then pack.
Yeah.
He was telling me though that that
packet was addicted to that though.
We would have to tell pacbio don't do
fucking sit ups today.
Why?
Because you know,
you take a day off,
let your muscles rest.
and he was like,
no,
he would just catch them.
Just doing them all the time and he
would do like a thousand sit ups.
Something stupid.
I was,
I couldn't get him to stop doing sit
ups.
He couldn't stop.
He was addicted to doing sit ups.
That's so bizarre.
That's the one thing that most people
hate.
yeah.
I,
I hated these weird planking things.
He made me do hate them.
Oh,
look on your elbows.
Not even on my elbows,
on the medicine ball.
A half ball,
you know,
he'd turn it upside down and I would,
I would be on that and then my feet
would be on a medicine ball,
so I'd be at that angle is struggling
the whole time and they just make you
stand there for 30 seconds,
10 seconds,
15 seconds.
It's a long time now.
How'D you get in touch with that guy?
Uh,
from,
you know,
ellie sec back?
No.
does ess news?
He's a boxing kitty.
oh,
I know the name.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
put me in touch with them.
That's a weird guy to get as a trainer
though,
isn't it?
Because I wanted to get what the problem
was.
I wanted to get skinny,
I wanted to lose weight,
I wanted to get small,
but he's a,
you know,
alex is one of those guys who's like,
no,
I want to make sure you're fit and
you're in shape.
And I'm like,
dude,
I just got.
I looked the same,
but my,
like I was more fit,
you know what I mean?
Like we hadn't lost any weight.
I know I lost a fat percentage and gain
muscle mass,
but that's not what I wanted.
What I want.
I don't have a fucking fight coming up.
I just wanted to get skinny.
I just want to slim down.
Yeah.
Give me aids perhaps.
Could you really say that?
How dare you right now?
Easy east spinning in his grave.
Well,
I don't know.
Do you think you really had eight?
Uh,
I would.
it would,
it would appear.
So I don't think anybody would want to
fake that one.
Usually.
Now when somebody dies of aids and they
don't want to say it,
they just say he had pneumonia.
Well how few heterosexual people got
aids.
That's what's Interesting.
You know,
it's true.
It is a difficult way to get it.
Will chamberlain didn't get aids.
How does anybody have aids?
Yeah,
right.
And magic johnson and all this.
Well he did.
He got the hip,
but apparently he read.
He reads clear now.
That's what the word on the street Is
that his tests.
Yeah.
I don't understand that.
Um,
apparently you can get the hiv to such a
level that your body doesn't detect it.
Yeah.
It's all very confusing.
DIseases are very confusing.
Commenting on any of that stuff.
Like where's the aides were,
where did it go?
Come on.
Everybody thought by the time this 2016
rolled around,
we don't have it yet with all of aids
were.
I'll be dead,
right?
Yeah.
And then chris rock did the job 20 years
ago.
I remember.
What was that?
You're aids is acting up.
It's.
He said aids is just going to get to a
point where just manageable with
medications as well.
That's right.
And it's basically where we're at right
now.
What's even crazier than manageable?
It's nonexistent.
Do remember when sam kennison had that
bit about it?
Sam kennison.
I like the most controversial bed.
Is she?
He's like sam,
they say it's a,
it's a,
it's a communicable disease.
Heterosexuals can die from it too.
He goes,
name one name one fucking god.
Damn.
why?
Because it's not dance.
Maybe had that thing about rock hudson.
Oh,
I remember that.
You know,
rockets had had to be on his deathbed.
Gone.
It was her last fucking dick.
What was that last day?
Why don't I suck at dick's?
Nothing ever went wrong.
dictate.
What was that last big.
Oh,
that guy,
man.
That's the guy that you can't.
That's,
that's a,
that's a real revolution in comedy.
It's only been like a few,
like real revolutions.
There's a.
Yeah,
there's that distinctive voice that
people get,
right?
There's the mellow guys.
Then there's the,
uh,
if anybody does try to go that route,
it's always trying to do sam and now
there's the people that want to be mitch
and then there's the,
uh,
people that want to be bill or louis.
The bill one was awesome because there
was so many people that were trying to
be like hicks.
There was a,
there was so many.
There's so many like hicks clones,
especially after he died and everybody's
like,
I'm going to pick up the mantle.
I'm going to be that tortured road
warrior writes poems.
Yeah.
See to me hicks.
I always read to me as an angry,
dorky guy,
angry nerd.
That's how I always.
Yeah.
I never looked at them going,
okay,
so cool sam.
I looked at it,
but like,
it's kind of cool.
He's very rock and roll.
You know what's hilarious is ari should
fear like challenges people.
He goes,
he wasn't funny.
show me one joke or hicks was funny and
people get crazy.
They get so mad.
They attack him.
they go after him.
He's like,
Yeah,
good point.
You made a good point but not funny.
Next,
I'm with ari on this.
I was never a hicks fan,
but I'm a fan.
I'm a big fan.
ALways will be.
I'm a fan of what he did,
like the style.
I was very fascinating to me to watch,
but he definitely wasn't the most
hilarious guy.
It wasn't like joey diaz,
like you watch them and you can't stop
laughing.
You're just crying.
I think kettler is a better version of
hicks.
tendler how?
How so?
I mean ken lawyers got that fucking
sharpness to them and.
But he's a lot of sticky stuff and he
does some sticky stuff.
But you almost know he's doing it on
purpose.
Oh,
he definitely is.
Yeah.
So.
But again,
he's also one of those guys that only
comics know about our love.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Those I always felt like kindler would
catch on.
He wasn't you.
He was on somebody's sick.
Come from and it was he.
Yeah.
What's it come to kindler and thinking
about patent?
No,
because I was on a siTcom.
Patent was on kevin.
James had come to think andy kindler
dropped in on that every now and then to
diddy or was it drew carey's?
One of them.
Do you got that info?
bob's burgers.
What's bob's burgers cartoon?
I did a voice on bob's burgers.
He's on marin.
He's on marin as a guest every now and
then.
Or was he on anything else?
Hmm.
Comedy bang
comedy.
Bang.
What is that?
That's.
I'm reggie watts.
This thing,
wasn't it?
Reggie watts is on that new show where
he's the bad guy for that.
James corden?
Yeah.
Have you watched that show?
I haven't.
No.
Good for you.
Stay away from that tv.
Go read a book.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh,
he was.
okay.
Everybody loves raymond.
the sitcom is a sitcom.
A sitcom is dead as we know.
What I think.
Yeah.
Seems like it.
Well,
the,
the uh,
the traditional sitcom is dead.
Do you sit around thinking about things
you can do or do you just do one more
time?
Yeah,
I think about all the time.
Rubin,
paul and I have an idea for a show,
but we don't know which way to go.
That's the thing that want you to say it
on the air so someone could steal it.
I mean,
I know that's what I'm not saying it to
my life.
So you can't steal my life.
You could try as ease and sorry,
I start gaining weight.
He was son of a bitCh.
I'm outta here.
I went there motherfucker.
I don't give a shit.
I'm smoking a joint even though you
don't smoke pot.
How come you don't smoke?
Pot was talking about.
Uh,
I didn't like the way I felt on it.
I didn't like feeling slow makes you
feels low.
Yeah.
I also like just dopey.
I felt like hmm.
Like to mellow,
which I didn't want to feel.
Are you sure you smoking the right shit?
I mean,
I,
you know,
this was the,
there was the nineties when I tried it,
the nineties.
TheY hadn't figured out sativa yet.
No.
Maybe they did know where they figured
out back then.
Back then it was either a,
you either had a cess or.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Or,
or,
uh,
or fucking little g kush chronic.
Not even.
I was in toronto,
so it was like either jamaican stuff or
hydro stuff.
What about edibles?
That's what fucked me up.
Oh,
I didn't have a bowl 11 or 12 years ago.
Yeah.
One of those little two bite brownies.
But I did not know he was supposed to
only have one bite.
Oh,
that's,
that's fucked up.
More people like eating too much
edibles.
As fucked up.
More people with pot than probably
anything ever.
Yeah.
I ate the whole brownie and wanted to
fucking die.
I'm sure you've seen the nine slash 11
video.
That was on a youtube of the cops that
called nine slash 11 because there was a
guy they pulled over.
He had some pot,
they stole the pot from him and made
brownies with it and ate the brownies
and thought the brownies were poisoned
and thought they were dying.
I thought they were dead.
Were like times moving really slow.
I never seen that.
No.
Oh,
fire that up jamie.
If I find that please.
It's hilarious.
It's fucking hilarious because this is
what happens.
like marijuana.
I've said this before,
so please forgive me if you've heard
this and you're listening.
Marijuana,
when you eat it,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite that's five times more
psychoactive than thc.
Right?
So there's thc which you get when you
smoke it and then when you eat it,
it's a totally different drug.
So when people go,
oh my god,
this is not pot,
somethings in this.
Now that's pot.
When you eat it pot,
when you need it,
it's like a totally different dimension.
You open a different door,
you go down a different hallway,
you're in a different.
You like,
this is
not pot pot that's partly eat.
I was stuck to the bed,
literally like laying in a,
you know,
put spread eagle.
oh,
the nine one.
One call for the cops.
The cops called nine slash 11 for the
was calling.
I was literally.
My nails were.
Yeah.
I thought I was going to like,
the bed was going to fly.
Yeah,
I've been there dude.
And I was all I could do as mumble.
I couldn't even muster words out of
mouth.
My tongue was dead.
It was so my favorite way to be scared.
The shit out of me.
What I like about being there is that
you always come back like you really
think you're going to die,
but you always come back and you're
always fine and you come back here.
Listen to this
two
pot brownie over chemistry,
an overdose.
And my wife.
Have you and your wife overdose of what?
Marijuana.
I don't know if it had something in it.
Oh,
okay.
Can you please send rescue?
Okay.
How old are you?
I'm 28.
Twenty nine years old and my wife is a
26.
Please call them?
Yes,
please.
Hey.
Thinking also,
what have you guys been drinking
tonight?
You know,
that's it.
And is there any weapons in the house?
No,
please come on.
You guys like you guys have anything?
No,
I'm just,
I think we're dying.
How much did you guys have?
A.
I don't know.
We made brownies and I think we're dead.
I really do.
Okay.
And what,
how much did you put in the brownies?
I don't know.
I hit him back.
Um,
my wife and I did two book.
Come here.
Get her.
She's on the.
She's on the living room ground right
now
on the grant
breathing.
Is she awake?
Think so.
Okay.
Can you log?
pardon?
Can you,
can you just
down in front of the time is going by
really,
really slow and putting the brownies.
Pardon?
Yeah.
How much did you buy?
I don't police and rescue.
I'm trying to think of how much you
bought and put it into the brownies.
PrObably like a quarter on total from
the brownies and you guys eat all?
Yeah,
we dId.
It wasn't a big patch.
A little bad.
It was,
it was a quarter ounce.
Okay.
But brownie wise,
how many pieces do you guys think you
guys had?
I don't know.
I probably had like a small child.
Please tell them it's.
What time is it?
Nine 37.
When did you last eat the brownies?
Probably like an hour and a half ago.
Okay.
Is your wife,
so he.
Is your wife still brina?
Yes.
She's sitting,
kneeling down in front of me.
She's moving.
I know.
Have to wait.
Okay.
And she says yes.
What's your name?
My name is edward edward fansa.
Okay.
And did you guys have any?
We get it.
It goes on for awhile.
But what's hilarious is the lady who um,
who answered the phone,
she didn't even bother.
Like she didn't rush,
she knew they were fine beCause she was
sober.
like that's my favorite thing.
She just keeps asking questions.
Like if that was a gunshot wound when
she'd be asking so many questions,
where are you?
Have somebody like blacked out.
They think they had a heart attack.
Shouldn't be asking so many questions
for these dummies.
One of my friends had one a couple of
years ago when he came out here to see
us.
He had a cookie and when it hit him,
he,
he turned fucking so pasty,
white and any.
He thought he was dying is the same.
Same exact same reaction.
I even called my doctor for him because
you know,
I'm like,
anything I could do.
He goes,
no,
just tell him to relax.
He's got to wear off.
That's all.
You can drink some water
if you really feel like you're done
though,
you really do.
You really feel like,
man,
I really fucked up.
Yeah,
this is.
It's over,
man.
He was done.
What'd you get back?
So what should I try?
Shouldn't try anything.
If you don't want to mean you're a happy
guy,
american guy.
I would not look at you and say,
Russell Peters needs anything in his
life other than what he's enjoying me
some tequila.
I do too.
Yeah.
It's just the health consequences of
that stuff are just so different than
what happens with pot when I was with
pot is drum roll.
Nothing.
That's nothing.
You get high as fuck.
The next day you go to the gym,
you feel great,
like there's no health consequences.
If I get drunk and had been drunk,
I feel like shit.
The next day man.
I just feel like shit.
But what are you drinking?
Anything.
If I drink too muCh wine,
I feel like shit the next day.
Yeah,
if I drink too much whiskey,
I feel like shit.
The next day.
If I drink too much beer,
I feel like shit.
The next day I work out,
I could feel it.
I feel like weakened
tequila.
I feel fine.
The next day you're a maniac.
That's open.
That's all.
Just just drink.
drink it straight.
Whoa.
That's terrible advice.
You don't have to give it in.
This terrible event is you don't have to
have like fucking,
you know,
10 of them.
You just have,
you know.
I have maybe two glasses.
I sip.
I'm all night.
Brian painting
two shot before every show.
He does one shot before every show.
That seems like a damn good idea.
It's not a bad idea because your body
really doesn't have a hard time
processing one shot of whiskey,
like one shot of whiskey is like no big
deal.
IT's when you go like three,
four,
you have a beer.
Whoo.
I don't.
I don't mess around like that.
It's just straight tequila.
I'm a huge hunter s thompson fan and one
of the saddest things to me is watching
thompson from the time he was a really
young man when he first started making
it as a journalist and a writer to the
way was as he older and
I think a big,
big part of it was the alcohol.
Like he just drank so much booze that at
the end he was almost incoherent.
He would go on letterman and conan
o'brien and you've barely understood
what he was saying.
He just saw it.
It's like,
that stuff will fuck it.
Get you.
You know who almost sounded drunk with
hitchins?
Yes.
Well he was drunk a lot drunk.
He was drunk a lot and he smoked
cigarettes as well,
which is just so unfortunate for such a
brilliant guy.
Yeah.
You know he did smoke cigarettes,
right?
No,
he sounded like he did.
Doug stanhope.
What does it say?
See him.
A boost suit he had when he got on the
cruise.
No,
he snuck on all thIs.
How hottest smell this alcohol.
Smuggle booze on the cruise ship he's
wearing,
I don't know,
leaders of whiskey and vodka and mixers
in those things.
He had it all in bladders and tucked
into small plastic bag and hopes are
skinny now because you can't take this
stuff on a cruise ship.
I guess.
I've never been on one.
Yeah,
you can't.
Hilarious.
You can't because they want you to buy
their booze.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but they always have shit.
Booze on board.
They do.
So look at this.
He's got a suit on.
Oh my god.
Bags of whiskey.
This is so ridiculous.
Yeah,
tuck.
It's like someone in like a movie when
they're making jokes about like,
give me all your guns and they haven't
talked to.
Everybody
got everywhere,
but he's ruined it for everyone now.
Oh,
he's got it in his dick is got a tequila
tucked into his jockstrap.
Are you playing this volume of,
oh my god,
this is insane.
Socks.
A flask.
Oh my god.
it's enough for a party of 25 people.
Not for 20 fIve stan hope.
So that's the difference.
I love him.
That's what it looks like.
A norwegian cruise lines.
Impractical jokers.
Hilarious.
Smuggled.
Alcohol drop.
Drop,
drop,
drop.
Trout.
Chickens,
cats down.
I should have announced this.
We're doing an end of the world election
night,
um,
comedy podcast from the comedy store and
it's going to be stan hope and myself
and fitzsimmons is going to do it.
And we're probably goIng to have some
other people too.
And maybe Russell Peters.
I'll drop.
He's in cabbage in the date.
whatever the election day is.
Is that the third 70 elections on the
eighth?
So it will be the day.
God,
this election's weird,
man.
It's a,
it's a good time to be american guy.
This is a weird one.
This is a weird one because like,
um,
I think people just want to see it play
out.
Somebody tweeted,
I forgot who it was,
but it was hilarious.
I said,
I can't wait for them to see the series
finale of of America.
Wow.
It really almost feels like it.
You know you're going to vote,
right?
Yeah.
I guess we'll vote for Gary Johnson.
I think even though he doesn't know what
aleppo is,
you know,
when you know,
even though you know.
Here's the thing,
when I heard him ask,
when they,
when I heard them ask them that
question,
it sounded like they wanted to know what
he thought about something called leppo.
Oh,
what do you think about aleppo?
I think he said,
what are you going to do about it?
What are you going to do about aleppo?
And he was like,
I'm sorry.
Like I think the question just confused
them.
It's a really important thing to know if
you want to be elite.
I mean,
what has he been doing?
He's running for president now.
That takes up all of his time,
but how much was he doing when he was
the governor of New Mexico?
As far as like paying attention to world
issues,
I don't know how much you have to want
to know more than a regular person.
it's always weird that,
you know,
we'd get these,
uh,
these people running for president that
are from states where you're like,
do they think about the rest of the
world there right now?
You know,
Arkansas and New Mexico.
Yeah.
WeLl some.
I think more people do now than ever
before.
More people definitely think about the
rest of the world now than they did say
a 20 or 30 years ago.
Just because we're in,
we're in contact with people more,
you know,
the internet is given people more ideas,
more things to look up,
more things to think about.
But man,
not knowing aleppo,
you got to know all that.
And it's funny,
as I didn't know it,
I didn't know what at the time I didn't
know it.
I knew that there was tremendous issues
in Syria.
The name of the city was,
it sounded like a nickname for something
leppo and then I would,
you know,
being indian.
I was like,
how long it was the other one,
other
one though where he,
uh,
didn't know any world leaders and that's
a problem.
That's a big problem.
So that's a bigger problem than not
knowing aleppo.
Yeah,
you've got to be careful there.
Dude.
You gotta have some people that you
admire,
but I think it's up to somebody in your
business.
Yeah,
I think he said angela merkel right?
Is that what he said?
I don't even think he's.
I think his vice president threw that
out for him.
Yeah,
but that woman who's running for as his
bride,
who's his running mate,
some other dude,
bill weld,
former governor bill weld.
Oh,
building.
that's his vice president.
I should know that.
I've almost given up.
It's like I'm a cubs Fan.
It's like they're not going to win and
not going to win and not.
You know what I mean?
It might witness here.
They might've heard bob newhart's all
excited.
He's 87.
He saiD he was too old for this shit.
I love bob,
but those cubs fans,
man,
they hang in there.
No matteR what.
I gotta support toronto,
you know,
it's my city.
I understand even though I don't know a
damn thing about baseball,
but doesn't this seem like a,
it seems like a ridiculous sporting
event.
We really almost does.
It's almost like an who who can.
I demean an insult more to diminish them
more contest.
Like if you really thought
like that about like part of it is like
they'd go for the worst aspects of each
other and they try to like do it on live
tv.
It's an ugly precedent to set for the
country,
you know,
especially,
when they try to justify it.
I think by looking at the rest of the
world when they have elections in how it
gets really violent and all these other
parts of the world.
And you know,
you remember,
remember when some leaders,
I forget what country it is,
but somewhere in europe,
the leaders get into fights with each
other at the end and they're a
in their government offices.
Oh yeah.
They have fucking crazy gang fights.
Yeah.
There's one in
parliament or something like that.
I was in China.
Was it in China or there might've been
China or Korea.
I think it was curriculum again.
I saw the guy throw a cow.
I think so.
And they went nuts on each other.
He started fucking crane member.
And Ukraine is not the place you want to
do it.
And what if fatality clips goes to
running,
you're running,
you're running against him,
you know,
Ukraine people are
cut from a different cloth.
All those people from that part of the
world are.
So there's something like extra strong
about them,
you know,
the,
just the robustness of the people there.
A survivors.
Fuck yeah man.
It's Cold as shit up there.
Cold as shit.
And they were more.
They were oppressed for so many years.
Yeah.
You could take some dude who lives in
siberia,
some man and his wife from siberia.
Nigga russell.
I'm providing a coffee.
So.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Oh,
he may not be the best at it,
but he sure is the toughest edit.
Well,
la wasn't corel and from siberia as well
as alexander karelin the wrestler.
Uh,
I could not confirm or deny this,
you know,
that is,
I do not do maybe the scariest guy of
all time in the history of russian
athletes.
There's one guy who stands out.
The only wrestling match he lost in the
olympics was to rule on gardner.
I think that was the only in his entire
amateur career.
And I,
I might be wrong about that,
but I know he lost to in the olympics.
And the only reason why I lost to him,
it was like some new rule where if you
separated the hands it would be a point.
It was the first time that was ever in
the olympics.
So if you're [inaudible] the greco roman
cable grip and greco roman,
they do a bunch of shit,
but it's mostly upper body grappling and
collar ties.
They don't shoot doubles.
It's like it's a different style of
wrestling and corella and excelled at it
because he was a freak specimen.
But he's from siberia.
But he was like six foot,
three,
300 pounds.
Just a ridiculous guy.
And there's a picture of him hoisting
this guy in the air and I have it in my
gym.
I just stare at it all the time.
Like iF I ever,
if I ever taKe myself seriously,
this picture right here,
if ever want to know,
have really,
truly understand what a pussy I am.
I need to look at this picture of
chlorella and he's gritting his teeth
and he's hoisting this guy dude.
No mouth guard.
Look at the size of his fucking quads.
I mean he was a freak.
Giant calves.
He was for rick and he fucking rag doll
dudes now.
Well he's a,
he's a wrestling coach now,
I believe.
If I had a guess,
I would say he's probably 55.
See how do he almost got went to mma in
the 19 nineties.
How old is he?
40 nine.
Something close.
And he almost went into mma in the 19
nineties.
It may have been the early two
thousands.
I think he was thinking about doing it
because there,
I know there were some offers and he
feel like he did some Pro wrestling
thing.
I think he might've done some like fake
wrestling thing,
like for money or something like that
with dude,
he was a four week,
just a freak and he would throw guys
around and this really ridiculous way
where they just,
they were like little children because
he was a big giant do like the size of
that mother guy,
but he was also really agile,
like he said,
like these roles that he could do these
dives.
He was so gentle anD a lot of his
movements but freakishly strong.
So he had achieved this spectacular
balance of incredible technique but
ridiculous freakish human athletic
ability.
So he had like the combination of those
things like look at his technique and
everything is perfect,
but he's also tremendously strong.
Like The russian wrestling coach.
It's rustling a russian wrestling is
incredibly technical.
While they're just the eastern bloc
countries,
like they have a super high level of
wrestling,
technical,
um,
technical skill.
Like a.
That's one of the reasons why george st
pierre.
So good because he was Training with
these russian nationals that came over
and lived in montreal.
That's where st pierre learned how to
wrestle.
He has a solid base to have these
incredible.
For a guy that is coming back,
I don't know that he keeps thinking
about it and talking about it,
but I think I'm sure you've heard the
rumors.
Yeah.
well they're talking about like a super
fight with anderson.
I don't knoW.
In toronto.
Uh,
no one's told that to me.
I have not heard that.
I heard it,
but I've not heard it from a human.
If I was,
if I was george and I was thinking right
now,
I think george st pierre is.
I mean there's only a small handful of
people as famous in the world of mma as
a fighter.
As george st pierre.
There's connor who's the most famous.
There's rhonda who's right up there.
Rhonda and connor.
Almost interchangeable in my eyes as far
as like how famous they are.
Maybe more conor because he's famous
worldwide.
I don't know,
man.
It's super close.
I think rhonda affected her legacy by
taking that year off.
Well,
that doesn't matter.
She comes back with a storm.
She beats Amanda Nunez,
get to the belt.
She's bigger than ever.
That's a tough one.
It's a verY tough one,
but if she does do it,
she's bigger than ever.
She's,
she's got that whatever it is,
that Dynamic personality that people get
attracted to and there's about
her losing and maybe even losing like
that,
that could even make it more attractive
to some folks,
you know,
it's,
it makes her more human,
makes them more vulnerable.
You know,
one of the things that people didn't
like about her was how confident and
strong she was.
Very invincible at the time.
Well,
and she was also like really aggressive
about it with other girls,
but you ain't,
you know,
in her eyes,
those girls will try and take something
from her when she was the Mike Tyson of,
uh,
of,
of mma.
That's the only way you get to be a
champion is if you have like that insane
belief in yourself.
But when you lose the way she lost to
holly,
which is,
you know,
a devastating knockout.
It's always inTeresting to see how
someone rebounds.
Some people rebound that become better.
They come back tougher and stronger and
that's what we're hoping,
let's you're hoping for.
But that was,
or some people come back,
they fight smarter.
That was george st pierre when george st
pierre got beaten up by matt serra.
Matt serra clobbered them,
just collaboratiVe,
clipped him,
heard him,
got on top of a mountain and punishment
of face,
bam tap.
And he'd beat the shit out of him.
And george came back better than ever.
He just regrouped.
But george also didn't take a year off
in between there.
It's true.
It's true on tv and you know,
you know,
list for sure.
And I just think was a different person.
You know,
I love rhonda,
but I,
I just,
I,
I'm hoping,
you know,
for her,
I'm a big fan of taking a long time off
when you get knocked out.
I think I understand that and think it's
real important.
It is very important.
However,
what you do in that time and how you
present yourself in that time is also
important.
Well,
she really do much.
She kind of laid low,
you know,
which I mean.
Nah,
nah,
I don't think so.
I see your point.
But I disagree.
I think she'd do whatever the fuck she
wants,
you know?
I mean,
I don't know that it really affected her
brand so much,
but he's telling me a marketing genius.
That's what I'm just thinking.
You should.
You should have a startup.
We should have a startup together.
Let's do it.
What do you want to do?
We'd do.
What do you think is wrong with taking a
year off?
Like nothings wrong with taking a year
off,
but you know that allen interview where
she was talking about contemplating
suicide.
Yeah,
I forgot about.
I mean I think those are the things that
showed the mental makeup and that's
where I think that's what's putting the
doubt and everybody's mind now.
If I had to do a brendan schaub right
now,
I'd say for sure.
Don't do your first interview with ellen
on tv.
Yeah.
And cry.
I don't know man.
Like I think I think those,
those tv formats,
although I've done them and I enjoyed
them.
When you do those things,
you can't.
You can't be yourself in seven minutes.
It's not enough time.
Especially if they don't know you and
the people you're talking to.
No,
no.
You either as a giant crowd of people
and their lights that say applause and
there's a guy had left.
Yeah,
the clapping instead of laughing at a
warm up guy walks around.
Guys who were coming back live.
You guys are super excited.
We're excited to have you.
Thanks for all your enthusiasm.
We're really appreciate
it.
I'm just going to need it.
Let's just 10,
10 percent more folks.
Come on.
We can do this.
So whatever you got and add 30 to it.
Now,
rhonda,
tell us about your head trauma and all
these people,
which I mean,
it's like.
It's bizarre.
It's a bizarre way to talk to people.
I think what you should have done was
talk to somebody in the fight game.
It would have been.
It would have been received a little bit
better because then she would have been
speaking to somebody knowledgeable
about,
well,
you know what man?
She can do whatever she wants to do.
I don't.
I don't know what was going on in her
head during that time,
but I don't think there's anything wrong
with taking a year off getting your head
together and she also had some injuries
she had to take care of.
Did you,
do you think she should have trained,
changed her a training camp?
I don't know what she's doing.
Honestly.
She's still right back at glendale fight
club.
Listen,
what whether or not that guy,
edmond has had success with some of his.
Some of his students who like what
issues they've had.
You can't deny that he's worked wonders
with her hands like her.
Her striking ability when she was
warming up for that batch code,
hey,
a fight,
and they were in Brazil,
they were on the sand and they're doing
these pad drills together.
Just look fantastic.
Right.
You look at her when she first started
striking,
you look at it until now.
That's a big percentage of that.
Is those two working together so there's
no denying there's some merit to what he
does.
Unquestionably.
He's definitely helping her.
You would have to examine the whole
camp,
like a scientist.
You'd have to sit down to do this,
right,
like you've got a world class world
championship level racehorse and a woman
like rhonda rousey,
right?
Or any fighter for that matter.
And if you were the overseer,
if you were someone who could say,
okay,
what is the best course of this thing?
Like how do you,
what?
You have to address technical issues.
You got to address psychological issues.
You got address,
comfort and attrition,
all these different things.
You'd say,
okay,
technically a,
what are we trying to achieve?
Victory,
right?
Like what is her best options?
Like is she training with the best kind
of sparring partners?
And the thing is you don't fucking know,
like one person could do it one way and
be super successful and everyone says,
well that's the way to do it.
You don't spar and you only do drills
and then your ride bikes and that's what
donald cerrone has been doing.
Or you could go the eddie alvarez route,
right?
And y'all responded like a 150 rounds
preparing for wholesale dos anjos.
So he went the other route.
He just said,
we're going fucking crazy.
We're going to go old school.
Crazy.
We're going to go in there and brawl and
just be comPletely prepared.
So ronnie doesn't continuously train
without sparring,
does he?
yes.
Yeah.
How long has he been doing that?
Since the fight with dos anjos he was
talking about.
He said you take too much punishment in
the gym.
It's like you're taking too much
punishment.
Sparring.
And he just,
he had some issues where I think he said
he closed his eyes and the equilibrium
was given out and he was falling and he
was like,
what the fuck?
He realized it was he found out
later.
Is he an inner ear issue?
I think he was right here in like a,
like a vertigo type thing.
Oh,
it was so good dose clogging one that
had affected his inner ear.
I think it was like an infection in some
way.
but um,
so he decided just let's just do drills.
I know how to fight and he's had
incredible results.
So I think someone else is doing that.
The frequency that serone fights it as
well.
He,
he can probably get by without doing
that because he's in the ring enough
where he doesn't need to be in the ring
extra.
I think you're right.
I think there's that too.
It's like a comfortable balance and it's
probably one of the reasons why he likes
to fight so much.
He's probably,
he's easily the most active fighter in
the game.
He definitely tries to be.
Yeah.
But the problem also is like right now,
like setting up the right fight for a
guy like him is probably not that easy,
you know?
I mean he's always ready,
but he's always ready and um,
but setting up a fight for him,
it's like,
you know,
it's a high profile fight,
but it's also a dangerous fight.
So you've got to say,
okay,
well who do you set them up with?
[inaudible] after you see what he did to
rick story,
you go,
holy shit.
Like donald at one seventies,
like some new thing.
Yeah.
He's a new thing,
like he's away healthier cyst.
It kills me to think that guy was
starving himself for all those years.
He's a big dude.
He's not small,
but at 1:55
he just didn't have the durability and
one 70.
god damn.
He's looking good.
It's amazing.
It's crazy sport,
isn't it?
You know,
I love it.
So you know,
and I love being there at those things
and,
and you know,
when you get to know the fighters and
stuff and you get a little inside
talking,
it's always interesting,
you know,
I know it is man,
because you know,
you realized when you,
when you meet them and you and you talk
to them that they're just guys doing a
job.
They're not looking at it as I just want
to be the toughest guy in the world.
They're like,
I got to get more money out of this.
Well,
there's definitely that aspect of it,
but there's also the guys that just want
to go in there and be the toughest guy
in the world as well.
Those are usually the new guys
sometimes.
Yeah.
The older guys are like,
look,
I already know I'm tough and everybody
else knows I'm tough now.
I got to monetize this.
Yeah.
There's,
there's so many factors at play.
You know,
and when it comes to fighting,
there's genetics which plays a giant
role.
There's just,
there's certain guys that are,
is built better for it.
They just got a lucky roll,
the dice and they have better.
Just the design of their bodies better.
Yeah.
The shape is better.
It works better.
They can hit you harder.
their jaws bigger.
They can take more punishment.
Genetics on their side.
Yeah.
There's always gonna be guys like that.
So You're seeing guys like that now,
but then you seem like the mental aspect
of it.
How many gUys have mental coaches now
and hypnotists and chet?
It's such a weird game,
man.
dude,
you're still in any fight sport now is
very different than it was,
you know,
in the eighties when I was training
boxing,
there was no nutrition.
There was no.
yeah,
I would to.
I think I might have said it before my
car get to the gym.
I coach me like go run and I'm like,
yeah,
I just want to box.
He's like,
no,
we gotta go
run.
And then I would make all right and go,
where do I run to?
And he goes running up to,
you know,
tour bram and,
and,
and seven and come back and I'm like,
all right.
And right at that intersection was
mcdonald's just a little bit down.
So I would run to the mcdonald's and get
a milkshake and then I would walk back
because I made sure I ran there as fast
as I could to get a milkshake walk back
and then they would run on the issue in
the last half.
So I would be sweating it out a little
better,
a little bit out of breath when I got
there.
What do you think about this Amanda
Nunez?
Ronda rousey fight man doesn't do.
She's a beast.
She's bad.
She's bad ass.
I mean I would feel more comfortable if
she was coming back against meesha or
even a rematch against holly.
But,
uh,
amanda scares me dude.
Before holly knocked out rhonda,
I had said that I just thought holly
holm needed more fights in the ufc,
like more people to know who she is.
I'm like,
I go and I think Amanda Nunez the more
dangerous fight because Amanda Nunez is
a black belt in jujitsu.
Yep,
and she has fucking hard man.
She looks like she hits like a dude.
Yeah.
She had so much harder than most of the
women in that division.
She's super aggressive,
got shorter arms and she looks like she
can crank,
you know,
um,
this whole cyborg thing,
you know,
everybody wants cyborg to fight in the
ufc and trying to set up a fight.
I would like cyborG defined nunez.
Yeah.
I was just thinking that like much
confide in my pack on some weight.
So thing about cyborg is she struggles
to get to 40.
Yeah.
Like the,
she's so drained.
Is there a way above that?
There should be.
There should be a 1:45
or even give her the title at 1:45.
Who is denying that she's the toughest
145 pound woman on the planet.
Who's denying that?
I think there's a shit ton of fights
waiting to happen at 1:45.
One 50.
Even one.
Victor has a whole 145 pound division.
A bunch of them were messaging me.
There were tweeting at me after we were
talking about bringing this still around
the ufc owns it.
I thiNk the or the own part of it or
something or it's on fight pass or
something like those science.
But um,
yeah man,
she's a,
she's a a destroyer,
you know,
so I work as a destroyer.
Yup.
She's so terrifying.
The way she attacks these chicks,
like that's the 145 pound world champion
and she looks like mickey rourke.
So I think she's a little prettier
mickey,
right bro,
you're being rude.
I meant the lips.
I can't take this.
I can't take this in a tweet tour after
an apologize.
Apologize for kicking the shit out of
me.
But what's interesting is I wonder if
there is a 55,
is there a 55 pound division to be had?
Maybe one.
I'd go up to 1:48.
One 50 at the most I would say.
Hm.
I wonder,
because,
you know,
I think cyborgs,
one of her coaches were saying that if
you really,
her the right division will be 1:55,
I doubt would be the division where she
would feel that the healthiest because I
think she walks around at like one 70
something probably she's,
but she's all muscled,
you know,
it's not like she's walking around like
me.
She's walking around.
She's yoked.
Yeah.
But I'm Amanda Nunez is not that big.
It's just not as big as her know.
So that would be,
you know,
wouldn't be the wisest fight because
Amanda Nunez is like legitimate 135
pounder,
but she's a 135 pounder that hits like a
dude and she's very solidly built.
She's very.
So it's all very compact.
Did you see her fight with cat zingano?
I did not see how fucking ferocious cat
zingano is because she had cats and
gunnel hurt in the first round and she
was getting beat up,
like real bad.
The first round was real bad for cat and
she made it out of that round and she
stopped her and either the second or the
third,
I can't really remember.
See if you can remember that or you
don't remember it.
I Want to say she stopped her in the
third,
but it was just brutal fucking exchange
and she eventually beat Amanda Nunez.
Cats in Ghana is also knocked out.
Me should take people.
Forget about that.
Canceling jada's a beast.
I've.
What's that third round?
Tko cat stopped amanda.
But the first round did she had to
survive.
She was getting beat the fuck up and he
saw and that's all stand up.
[inaudible].
Well I think she got cracked and the
standup,
but I think most of it was ground and
pound on the ground if I remember
correctly.
But I'm amanda's just as far as like
her,
her punches from the outside.
She's got amazing snap,
like she really knows how to be in the
right position and she drops full,
like nothing punches on girls.
Like she really turned over.
It was a distance.
Oh dude.
She,
she cracks people.
So she cracked Sarah Mcmahon.
You see that fight?
I did not.
Dude,
you know,
a loT of times I catch I,
I jump in somewhere right around three
fights before the main event or two
fights before the main event.
yeah.
You're one of those cool guys.
No,
I watched the prelims and then I get
fucked up when I have to change the
channel because I'm like,
where did it go?
How am I finding this?
You know?
Yeah.
When you're there live though,
do you go for the whole event?
Do you get there very early after the
live event is a different animal.
Right?
Everybody should see a,
a ufc live while I was trying to get
your attention.
Good.
I'm on the wrong side of the octagon.
Just come over and grab me,
man.
Oh that was.
You can't go this way.
And I'm like,
all right,
well next time come with me.
I'll hook it up.
Um,
but I see the seats,
I see the seeds.
You get him.
and I'm like,
where are you?
And they're like,
I'm with joe.
And I'm like,
fuck,
that's a good seat.
You could do that.
We could do that.
Will hook it up.
How about toronto?
I'm not there for that one.
what is it?
December 10th?
Um,
something like that.
I'm doing a show with big jay oakerson.
I love jay massey hall.
Can I host it?
Fuck you.
That's it.
Russell peters big jay
and me.
You heard it here folks that a host
December 9th or whatever it is the day
before the ufc.
Yeah.
Tickets are not on sale yet.
They'll be on sale like in a week.
December the three of us.
That'll be a good old time.
Hell yeah.
Would be real fun.
Um,
but what we're just talking about.
Oh,
the um,
Amanda Nunez.
Ronda rousey fight.
But rhonda gets her to the ground.
Man.
It can be good if he gets super
interesting.
I would just like to see one tune up.
fight.
No,
no.
Tune up.
Finds this is not,
does not boxing.
Ufc doesn't give you enough.
They don't.
It's just a mountain.
You know what I will say though,
that the women have proven to have far
more resilience in the men.
A lot of times they're just fucking.
Their willingness to not tap and their
willingness to get in there and I prefer
to not compare them gender to gender
because I'm not one of those people,
so I just wanna let you know that
objectified them in my own little wake
up,
not knowing,
no need to even compare them to the men.
What I'll say is there's amazing
athletes and amazing champions in both
the men and the women's division summit
meeting legitimately now like there's.
There's no denying that there's world
class talent,
but there's also no denying that the
highest levels of male talent.
There's a bigger pool,
but that's natural because there's more
men that are interested in competing in
a male dominated sport,
but the women's side is growing and
you're getting a lot of like really high
level moitai fighters like valentino,
chef chanko,
so multiple time world champion who
comes over and now she's fighting and
she just beat holly holmes.
She'd beat holly holm and she really
like outclassed or with standup.
Like that was a big aspect of that was a
that I did see that and that was a.
Was a big shock for me.
I thought hollywood outbox or no
valentino's nasty dude.
Just get that beautiful check right hook
and she's.
She's real sneakY or their leg kicks.
She's got excellent timing.
She's a really dangerous fighter for
anybody in that division because if you
can't take her to the ground,
it's highly unlikely that you're going
to stand with her and not get cracked.
You're Gonna.
You're gonna.
Start getting real apprehensive about
your movements because she throws that
beautiful check.
Right hook,
or at least she did with holly.
She counters.
Well dude,
she's just real high level striker and
if you can't get into the ground and
even if you can get to the ground like
she's been working on her ground game
and she is very strong.
So there's suit like that.
Fight for a title shot though.
Yes.
Yeah.
She has.
I'm sure who she's fighting me should
know.
Who the fuck is.
She was writing me should I think me.
She was fighting someBody in mass note
and reaches fighting.
Raquel pennington.
Oh yeah.
Raquel pennington and meesha are
fighting in New York.
In New York city.
Yeah.
What?
Cal bennington's another one.
She doesn't get enough for respect.
She's dangerous.
Super aggressive.
Really good timing.
Good timing with her hands.
Are you doing those ones?
Yeah,
the math square garden one for sure.
Msg and new year's eve.
Oh yeah.
Like for me,
like a fight,
like the misha tate,
holly holm fight.
That's about as exciting a fight as
you're ever going to.
Fine.
That's exciting.
Fight is you'll ever see.
And the fact that there was a round in,
there were not much was happening around
her so we're not much was happening
where holly was trying to avoid nisha
and just was just striking on the
outside that made the ending even more
spectacular like the in that actually
made the fight better in the end because
it looked like holly was going to cruise
to a [inaudible] and I didn't know him.
He should've dug deep.
But uh,
so my all time favorite moments and then
flicking,
holly not didn't fuck.
She's like fuck you,
I'm not tapping.
Went to out throwing punches and it
looked like one of those puppets,
you know,
ones gangster.
So gangster,
the whole,
the whole fight.
So gangster.
And that was on the same card where nate
diaz beat conor.
Yeah,
I mean that was,
that was one of the main reasons why I
decided to stay doing commentary that
card because I was on the fence.
I was like,
wait,
no.
She just stopped doing it and then just
devote more towards.
Were you offered the uh,
bisping handle fight?
No,
I told him I'm not doing the ones that
are overseas message could find.
It was amazing.
I enjoyed it.
I watched it at home.
I sit here,
sit here.
We did a fight harder.
You wish you could've Been there to
commentate that one?
Nah,
I mean the fight companions are great,
but I'm saying no,
I'm just thinking brian stands awesome.
I think brian stands great.
A lot of shit from people that just
don't like things that are different or
they just pick a side or something like
that.
But I love.
It's kind of like.
I like brian,
I like kenny.
I like everybody does,
but you know,
you're that thing.
Yeah.
But they could be that thing too,
you know?
It was really good as dominick cruz.
Dominick cruz is very good,
very good.
Especially from the technical aspect and
so daniel cormier,
yeah,
I do like both of them when they do it
for,
for me is also spent so much time doing
the behind the desk stuff now that he's
gotten real comfortable with expressing
himself and like poetic and interesting
ways.
You know,
like his,
like when he's describing fights and
fight,
he gets hyped up about.
Has got great emotion to it.
It's entertaining as well as isn't
fighting anthony soon.
Yeah.
He's fighting rumble rematch,
excited,
rumble.
Man's coming.
So scary.
He is a very scary,
so scary at the fights in the audience
and I smiled because they're
acknowledged like,
hey man,
I need.
Yeah,
he did not fucking smile but a bad
motherfucker that run.
It wasn't like,
I hate you.
It was just like,
fuck you smiling it.
Now he's a good guy,
man.
Rumbles.
A good guy.
Very good guy.
And I'm like that.
But I gave him a smile and a nod and I
got to.
It's almost like he's got different kind
of bones,
like everybody else has bones that bruce
settled in the way he looks.
No,
it looked like his face.
I don't know why.
And just looking at and pick.
I was picture bruce selden.
That's weird.
Maybe of.
no.
Absolutely.
You know I'm a racist.
of course I am.
I hate everybody know.
Well,
rumble is a unique specimen.
It's just so hard to believe that he was
a 170 pounder for so long and it was
killing themselves to make that one 70
goes up to two.
Oh fIve.
And is one of the scariest guys
ever.
Yeah.
He said the scariest guys of all time
and I don't even know how he made one
70.
How the fuck did he make one 70?
I don't know that.
That's a young man's thing.
There's anthony.
Yeah.
He doesn't look anything like Bruce
Bruce sound and let's see.
Maybe not that picture.
No picture.
Very seldom rate.
I'm not kidding.
There's a picture.
There's a picture of bruce elden where
he looks really dark and that's not it.
Look,
hey,
look at that picture up there on the
right.
Seldom see the one where he's wearing
the red and white trunks?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
No,
you're racist.
That's me guys.
But we've got to remember.
Yeah,
rumble survived that storm the first
time.
You know,
the first fight that rumble and dc had
cormay survived.
Survived that storm and then put his own
storm on rumble.
You know me a is a,
he's such a world class wrestler and
he's just,
he's his,
his sparring partner is fucking cain
velasquez.
And the other one is luke rockhold.
So I'm going to daily.
He's sparrIng with those fucking guys
and they go hard and he's arguably one
of the best wrestlers to ever compete in
mma.
There's like a handful of guys you look
at as being in contention for being the
best wrestler to ever competed in mma.
Henry cejudo,
of course,
olympic gold medalists.
Now there's a few guys,
but cormier is in that mix,
like he's in the mix.
I mean they all give each other
something else.
So that's uh,
and I think that fucking aka camp where
it's him and came and they just smashing
heads together all the time.
You know,
it's funny when I'm up in northern cali,
I'll call whoever and I'm like,
hey,
I'm out here.
And they're like,
you want to come train?
And I'm like,
no,
they're going to come train at aka.
No thanks.
I'll call it called gill.
And he's like,
you want to come by scrap pack and
train.
I'm like,
nah,
I'm good.
But like my level is not anywhere near
anybody's level.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to hold,
get someone to hold pads 46 year old
man.
I'm not trying to.
I'm a chubby fucking indian guy.
it's fun to be around those places
though.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what does,
when you go and you see everybody go,
yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not built for this.
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a hobbyist.
These,
these guys are lifers.
You have to have the most insane
dedication,
I think for any athletic endeavor.
I think below 40 and I would have gone
and trained with them,
but I didn't know them then.
So
what's just a weird thing to dabble in?
Like dabbling in mma?
It's be really can't do it.
You have to be.
Unless you're some freak athlete.
There's always exceptions.
There's always people that just
ridiculous.
F like apparently that's what jon jones
was for the longest time before he moved
to albuquerque.
He would take time off and go back to
New York and,
you know,
train some out there but not trained
with anybody.
Like uh,
the people who's training with,
you know,
forest fights.
Everybody's out there in albuquerque
now.
Try it again.
Yeah.
Well he moved there and then once he
moved there,
I mean I think everything went up to the
next level,
but he's,
he was a guy that could take all that
time off,
come back and still fuck everybody up.
Just just a freak athlete.
Is he as well?
So they lifted his band or.
I don't know,
man.
I don't think you'd Be.
They sentenced him if he got sentenced,
sentenced conner $150,000
for a fucking water bottle.
Yeah,
that seemed a little access.
A tiny bit,
huh?
Why they do that?
Well,
it's not like he's a habitual bottle
thrower that we are finally punishing
you for this.
I'm sick of all of that bottle.
Throwing row is a stupid thing to do
though.
And it was a.
I mean,
come on.
Do you really think he going to hit
them?
You know,
it's too far away.
It wasn't.
I thought it was just hyped for the
fight and it's just how I ended up
finding a friend.
Like you threw a glass bottle.
He threw a fucking water.
Refuses to fight in las vegas after
$150,000.
Fine.
That's fair enough.
Well it's a good thing to get the vegas
people to recognize there's consequences
to this.
But the ufc so big right now they sell
out no matter who's fighting.
But yeah,
the ones 50 hours of community service.
Wow.
Fifty hours is a real weak.
So weak were the work flux you got to
do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's fucking ridiculous,
you know,
flex and flex and they really shouldn't
have thrown water bottles at each other
and monster energy drinks or whatever
they did that shit stupid.
You've got to fight eventually throw
things at each other.
You know,
you get a little amped up their young
kids,
you know,
but ultimately I think $150,000
fine is worth it for them.
The amount of money that they all made
that everybody made,
you know,
so the,
the government,
the athletic commission gets to step in,
slapping a little bit,
take a little cash,
make a,
make a stink out of it.
They get to protest it.
But the fact is that that press
conference where he threw that water
bottle at nate diaz is probably worth
$400,000
as far as profit.
You know,
how many more people got hyped up for
it?
People love a fight at a press
conference.
They love when someone throws.
Don't do it.
Folks,
if you're listening,
jon jones and daniel cormier,
that was one of the reasons why that
fight became such a big deal because at
the face off,
did they have to pay any fines after?
Fuck yeah,
they did.
Yeah,
I don't know how much they paid.
Well,
maybe that's what the problem is.
Maybe they want to discourage anybody
from doing this further.
Maybe they want to say it's as oldest
fight at any fight game is and it's also
a real.
Like the John Jones one in particular
was fucking real.
When daniel put his hand on john's neck
and pushed him back,
john was like,
fuck that.
That's just,
that's just not happening.
He didn't give a shit if there was a
million people around 50,000.
Yeah.
So john was fine.
$50,000
and was ordered to complete 40 hours of
community service and cormier was fine.
$9,000
in order to complete 20 hours of
community service.
So they made a distinction that core me
a was less guilty than john,
but cormier touched him first.
Did he?
yeah.
He grabbed his neck and pushed him back
because john got face to face with them
and touch bases with the fines
constituted 10th,
10 percent of each fighters respect
purse for the January 3rd fight.
Wow.
That doesn't.
That doesn't even make sense.
Little,
that's how little they made because that
really makes sense.
Night 90 grand really for the title
fight it,
man.
That sounds crazy.
I don't know what their deal is because
they get paid and then they have like
they have like a reported pay and then
they have a different pay like
percentage of paper views and a bunch of
different stuff,
but they always show it in the papers
and they don't show locker room bonuses.
I don't know what that means.
They do show get mad at me when you show
it.
Whereas if you go,
if you go to a I fall,
we're going to have to go to yahoo news.
It tells you the whole purse breakdowns
for everybody and then the bonus for the
nightly bonus and the percentage bonus.
No,
they do performance of the night bonuses
that make that public,
but they also do some weird locker room
bonus thing that I don't know what the
fuck that's all about.
It's what did they do to private
companies?
The point,
and it may just find roy as well.
Yeah,
they going to find it.
What did he say?
What'd you just put up
is jones' attorney was arguing that they
shouldn't be paying off a percentage of
the,
of their purses and courtney a is
scheduled to make a base pay of 90 for
the fight and also possible $90,000
bonus.
So
seems like a really low amounT.
I don't know.
It feels.
It feels like that's not right.
It's 10 percent.
I know what it's so low to be fighting
for the world title seems wrong.
I mean it seems incorrect.
Seems wrong to write it.
Seeing it all,
it's always seemed wrong to me at the
highest levels.
Those guys are making some serious cash.
Now what's interesting is how many,
how many people are going to reach that
level and what you're seeing is a lot of
people that are trying to sort of
generate public interest the same way
conor stone.
So there's like guys who really never
really trashed,
talked before.
We're really in a trash talking.
They're not good at it.
What?
It's.
It's awkward and it's uncomfortable.
And here's the thing is if you were,
if your economy mcgregor and it comes
natural and that's what you do and
that's one thing,
but if you're like you've got a strategy
and your strategy is to be the
controversial guy and you're going to
get everybody to pay attention to you.
Like,
whoa,
that's a lot of work,
man.
I mean,
nate is what nate is.
Yeah,
exactly.
So in on one hand it's also not what
martial arts are at their best,
like at the very best,
they're two guys who want to compete and
test themselves against each other at
the very highest level.
RIght?
And when we think of a martial artist,
we don't think of some dude who's
insulting and spitting
on them and throwing water bombing they,
they're trying to take the thug aspect
out of it,
which is fair.
When you think of,
when you think back to what it was,
I was Bruce Lee,
everybody respecting and bowing and you
know,
yeah,
now it's just,
you know,
a lot of meatheads who know how to
fight.
you know,
there's definitely that too.
But to achieve the level of like a world
class level,
you have to have so much control over
who you are.
You have to be able to figure out where
all your personality pitfalls are and
sooth out all the bullshit in your life
and concentrate on the work.
It's such a weird sport,
man.
There's no sport that carries the
consequences of Loss.
Like mma does a boxIng as well.
Boxing is pretty close.
But mma,
like I think in mma you can have a loss
and still come back and it doesn't
affect you that much.
You think it doesn't box and boxing
because it's so fucking shady.
Inboxing.
Oh,
he lost.
No.
Good.
we need somebody else,
a,
an undefeated record,
and boxing means a lot more than it does
in mma.
Well,
there's only been a few,
right,
right.
That's what everybody strives for.
They strive for that gennady golovkin.
Perfect.
undefeated record as they go Into the
big fight,
you know,
but that didn't harm canelo I think
canelo stock rose in the floyd
mayweather fight.
yeah,
because he was so young and I honest,
I was at that fight as a matter of fact,
and I think that floyd could have
stopped canelo in that fight if he
really wanted to.
You think so?
Yeah.
He was just hitting them at will and you
could see canelo going back.
I mean all he had to do was just put a
little bit more pressure on them.
But I think floyd being somewhat
compassionate was like,
man,
if I stopped this kid a little,
it might ruin his career.
So.
Wow.
You really think that?
I think that.
Wow,
that's an interesting way of looking at
it.
I didn't think so.
I thought he's not taking any chances.
He's boxing smart and canelo can still
pop and he carries that populate into
the fight and he's dangerous.
So if floyd opened up to try to really
hurt him and stop him,
he ran the risk of being countered a
master.
He's very,
he's canelo is not as fast as floyd,
but his timing's really good.
He said it is,
but at that time he was still very
green.
Floyd really was in the,
in the zone,
in that fight.
He was just hItting them pop,
pop,
and then he would hit crank or right
hand on them.
You see canelo go back a little bit,
you know,
I think canelo's chin's a little
overrated a really.
we saw that when,
uh,
who the fuck knocked them down and like
the first or second round one fight.
Yeah.
Somebody knocked him down fairly
recently.
Right now maybe about around four or
five fights ago,
maybe before three,
four years ago.
Yeah.
It was a younger canelo then.
But um,
do you what I'm talking about?
No,
I don't.
I definitely don't think he has a bad
chin.
But anybody can get knocked down.
Especially early in your career,
you know,
especially progressive guys also heard
that canelo sparred with golovkin
before.
Oh yeah,
go off.
Can beat the piss out of him.
Inspiring.
And that's why he's saying no thanks.
Not interested in that.
Just trying to.
I think he's just trying to sharpen up
his skillset before he gets back in
there with him.
Yeah man.
I don't know how many triple g knockdown
kovalev inspiring diddy.
I had heard that.
yeah,
he said it.
He goes,
you know,
he hits really hard because I wasn't
prepared that day.
But wow.
Said there are also very good friends as
well.
Golovkin scary guy because he looks like
some cute little boy band.
He does not look like you can do.
It.
Doesn't even look like a throws with
power.
It looks like he's from a russian boy
band.
So he just so goofy.
Yeah,
he's adorable.
And if you look at his body,
it's not the scariest body.
It's just not chiseled.
It's just he's a thin guy.
She rumbled knocking people out.
You look at his body go,
well that make sense.
You know,
you see glove can knocking people out
and you go,
wow,
where's that coming from?
I don't know that she doesn't have a
huge legs.
He doesn't have a particularly big
traps.
Sees.
he jumped there.
He's got flawless technique though
flawless.
We had over 300 amateur fights,
you know,
he's so aggressive to.
He so fucking,
he's so aggressive and he keeps a pace
on guys that's very difficult to handle.
And he also,
you know,
people go,
oh,
he's beatable.
I'm like,
I just think he does things for the
fight game.
Like I know I can knock you out.
I'm just going to let you.
I'm going to extend this a little bit.
Just give people.
Yeah.
It's almost sets the two,
but you see him do it.
You can see like he basically just,
you know,
I'm going to gEt,
I'm going to make it look like a gun to
comfortable with you when you know at
any point and just like,
all right,
good night,
good night.
You know,
and he could do it at any point while he
definitely,
if he wants to risk getting hit,
but he bleeds guys,
you know,
he stops them.
He's a left hook to the body,
you know,
he,
he stays on guys with combinations and
he's always pressing forward.
Like you never,
you never rest with that guy.
Yeah.
He doesn't,
he doesn't move back for it.
Yeah.
It's a really interesting style because
uh,
another guy who's got a crazy style like
that as was silly.
Lowman chenko oh,
woman chank was probably one of the best
fighters in the game right now saying
he's fighting a nicky walters.
Is that his name?
I don't know.
Started the jamaican kid.
Yeah,
that's gonna Be a good fight.
He's another guy that like if you wantEd
to see beautiful technical movement and
defensive movement in boxing.
When I was training with a reason,
we would go to training robert garcia's
jim.
Oh yeah.
And lowman chanko would Be there every
now and then.
TheRe he is like,
look at a little guy too.
He's just standing right in front of
people,
beating them up and slipping everything
they throw at them.
God is so good,
slick and accurate.
Look at that moves just enough
[inaudible] look at this like knowing
exactly what's coming and when.
DamN,
he's
a really interesting fighter as well
because he's so hard to hit,
but he's also so aggressive.
It's wEird like that's not hands down,
hands down,
but he's lost in boxing and pro boxing.
He lost that mexican dude.
Fuck's his name.
Hoodie moves to lose to a old old
warrior veteran.
Sully's omar orlando.
That's right.
Leaders a warrior to.
Yeah.
A guy's been around forever.
yeah,
it is.
That's what hE's fighting next.
And nicholas volunteers.
Well,
he's definitely putting some attention
on these.
A lighter split decisions.
I mean,
you know,
whenever it's a split decision,
it could be like.
It could have gone either way.
Yeah.
It was apparently a crazy war and he
wants to fight him again.
Do you think hendo bisbing should have
been a draw or a split decision?
I think the scoring system sucks.
Yeah.
Some people said that that first round
wasn't a 10,
eight round.
That wasn't.
That was more than attending.
That might've been a fucking 10.
Seven around.
It's definitely a 10.
Eight for sure,
because he knocked him down.
He had him,
brock,
he's standing on top of it and bisping
survived for sure.
I mean bisbing showed true grit.
He got through that.
He pressed on,
but he was in a world of shit and I
think he would admit it.
It's face shows it.
I mean there's all beat up.
So that's a,
that's a significant round.
And then there was another round where
handle knocked him down again,
right?
yep.
So that was the second or third.
It's hard to tell man,
but the other thing that balance that
out was that bisping was way more active
and you got to take that into account.
It's not like bisping was landing all
those shots and attacking because
handled.
Let them know because he was imposing
his game on henderson.
Then the question is like,
is henderson's game more impactful?
Maybe,
but there's less impacts.
okay.
Well then what about damage or damage
wise was wiscat?
Gave bisping a first round.
Who did the first judge white?
No,
fuck why?
Yeah,
look,
they all.
The first one is the top row is the
second round right here.
Oh,
okay.
Second round.
There were.
Look,
eVen that guy gave him the first part.
Okay,
so you gave it to him around.
That.
gave a.
henderson was the second.
So then he made the first.
The first two rounds he made the first
night at 10.
Nine.
Ten,
nine.
Y'all made it a 10.
Nine c.
That'S not smart.
That's not smart.
That's not right.
The minute there's a knockdown like
that,
it's got to be a 10,
eight round.
It's not just a knock down.
It wasn't like a knockdown in boxing.
Makes a 10,
10 round 10.
Nine route or a 10.
Eight round.
Yeah.
I give them their evened up.
It'll make it a nine,
nine round,
but for the most part it's a 10,
eight round.
Right?
A guy knocks the guy down,
knocked down.
You got the first one,
the round,
then you've got the out,
but it's a fact.
There's no facts in mma when it comes to
that.
There's no like one thing that happens
where you definitely take a point off.
We know that with boxing,
Right?
Well,
with mma that wasn't just a knock down.
There was a knock down and then followed
by some fucking for roche's hair raising
ground impound.
He got elbowed.
He got punched,
he got beat up.
He got out of their faces,
bleeding.
His eyes closed.
You can't say that wasn't close to being
stopped.
You've to you to be on the brink of
being stopped.
So that round I disagree with across the
board and then it's trying to figure out
who won the other rounds.
There was the other one.
We're hindou heard him.
What brand was that was the second round
that he heard him again,
you know,
most things.
So yeah,
the second round he heard them again.
And then do you have to argue about the
fourth and the fifth rounds?
You have to figure out who knows?
It's a.
It was a close fight,
but I could see.
I coulD see the way many people thought
that bisping lanDed more and even though
they weren't as impactful,
you have to.
You have to add that up against the
lower volume,
but more power by henderson.
It's about effectiveness,
right?
Yeah.
Well see henderson at the end of the
fight looked like he just got done
sparring and bisbing looked like he just
got done with a fight with henderson.
You know,
we really would have looked lIke he went
through five rounds with one of the
toughest fucking guys ever.
The question is who want it?
I think the system is flawed.
I could see under the system that we
have today that bisping won that fight.
I see it.
I have volume.
Could see it as a draw.
I could see it as a fair draw and I
could see that too and that would have
been a very fair outcome.
I can see that too.
I definitely don't think there's been
good enough to beat dan and I don't
think dan did enough to beat bisping.
That's a good argument.
It's a real good argument and I think if
there's ever a fight where you could say
a draw might be justified,
that's one.
If you look online,
like people think bisbing one versus
people think henderson one,
it's pretty much split down the middle
except english people of course.
AnD even american people.
There's a lot of american people that
think bisbing one.
So,
uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a flawed system.
The system's going judge.
Uh,
uh,
what's it called?
Medical suspension.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That ain't good for you online.
Well,
they looked at fighting.
Let's settle down.
Everybody relax for a little while.
Was you just went to war with a fucking
meat machine,
like a cleaver who was telling me that a
henderson and we're hanging out and
having just punched him like as a joke
because he hits a whole fucking hard.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
It was like,
wow,
what the fuck did.
I don't think it makes sense.
He's just got one of those weird frames.
There's some people that just have power
that just doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
Just like regular power and then,
you know,
there's that henderson,
that rumble thing.
Yeah.
I need to step in and crank the right
way in order to get power.
I don't have that.
Just I'm going to hit you and you're
going to feel power.
It's dino's got it.
That's scary that john linacre kid,
that little guy,
he used to fight at 1:25
and now,
uh,
he's fight.
He fought at 1:35
in his last fight,
but ms dot weight and beat John Dodson
and literally close decision.
But he's a,
he's got that weird,
spooky power for a little guy for 1:35.
It's kind of read through the little
guys that have that have some heavy
hands and he's got the heaviest,
heaviest I've ever seen in this
division.
He's a clobber who just gets guys up
against the cage and just clobbered
them.
And it's one of those things where when
they feel the power of the first time he
could see in their eyes like,
holy wouldn't golovkin hits somebody see
it in their face immediately.
And I've never seen people wince until
they got hit by him.
Yeah,
he's something special for sure.
People,
every time they get hit and you look at
her face,
oh,
what the fuck do you know?
His boxing fights don't have much paY
per view buys though,
because it's not,
you know,
that's crazy to me though.
He's,
he's so exciting.
He's exciting.
But there,
you know,
he's with tom loffler and who's tom
loffler?
That's his promoter and it was just
promoter fuck up.
No,
it just that tom Walker does not have
the connections.
I think that bob arum or,
or a fucking floyd made with heR.
Uh,
yeah.
What's his name there?
Al haymon has.
Well golden boy,
right?
Golden boy and rochdale oscar de la
hoya.
And then there's ain't no,
but alan hayman's the guy really who's
got all the connects and I like how they
take in fighters there too.
Like bernard hopkins is one of the
partners over there and it's a.
They seem to do a good job.
What's a crazy thing to go from being a
fighter to being a promoter.
Yeah.
And then realizing you're making way
more money as a promoter.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Not in the line of fire at all.
They're like,
this is bullshit.
I think hopkins is going to take one
more fight though.
Yeah,
I think so.
Just to get it out of the garden at
least 50,
right?
He's 51 this yeaR now or the next year.
Incredible.
Never been out of shape though.
I know he needs a super,
super disciplined guy,
but it's just amazing that he's willing
to do one more fight at this age.
And,
and then of course,
being a successful promoter now you know
that you don't leave fighting,
fighting,
you know,
hopkins or 52nd fight before my 52nd
birthday.
January is who's gonna say how's he
going to do that?
Who is he going to say?
December.
Somewhere in la.
Probably at the forum.
December in la.
Dude,
we should go.
I man,
it'd be the last time bernard hopkins
ever fights.
We should go telecast.
Dude.
We got to go over.
I want to be there for that long is.
Oh,
I was uh,
I was at that sillitoe takashi.
More fight.
So that's going to be.
What date is it?
December.
Say it could take place at this one.
It says it doesn't have a date on it.
Okay.
No,
they're having a rematch again.
Who?
Salito takashi moira.
Oh really?
Right.
Let's just start this fight.
Orlando salido,
who's the first guy to beat low and
chanko yet this week,
so October 12th.
INteresting.
Well,
you know,
I always look back to when bernard
hopkins fought tito trinidad.
Oh yeah.
Through the flag down in puerto rico and
they.
They wanted to kill him and I was like,
oh,
I think I remember that time was a trend
that is going to knock him out.
They stopped trinidad.
He beat the shit out of trend dad.
He didn't just beat the shit out of him.
He boxes face off before he beat the
shit out of him.
Wasn't at hopkins,
I think it was hopkins that I'm almost
sure it was hopkins.
He had a fight.
This was in probably the late nineties.
The guy somehow got under him and body
slammed him and he dislocated his
shoulder and they were like,
we could stop the fight and you could
win by ignore decision because.
Nope,
it was.
He dislocated his right hand.
His right shoulder.
Yeah.
Well,
didn't eat.
No,
I don't remember that.
I remember one time he wasn't gonna get
thrown out.
He dislocated his shoulder and they
stopped the fight.
No,
they stopped the fIght because of him
getting thrown out of the ring.
Maybe you got thrown othering more than
once.
Yeah.
I think this was against antwan eccles,
if I'm not mistaken.
Hm.
Why knew he got thrown out of the ring
against one guy?
I remember he showed shoulder dislocated
and then he still went next round and he
stopped him with his left hand.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
I don't remember that at all.
It might not have been hopkins,
but I remember this one.
Was it?
Was it Chad dawson?
The dawson do that against.
No,
no,
it was.
It was definitely not Chad,
Chad dawson's and other guy.
Well,
whoever it was
for antwan echoes being in the mix and
name is spelled a n,
t w
and hopkins shoulder hurt after dawson
throws him down.
Fight ends in the.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
So yeah,
it was Chad dawson,
but I feel like.
No.
See it said it was Chad dawson,
but it was.
He'd also had this happen before.
Before this fight because Chad dawson
was fairly recently.
It was like in the later.
The late nineties.
Yeah,
exactly.
When hopkins was not a
just located.
Yeah,
it was just.
If you just google hopkins record.
Yeah.
this is not an exciting podcast to
listen to while we're googling bernard
hopkins record so we can remember my
shit.
THe bed on the joe rogan experience.
I don't think it was a loss.
I think it was okay.
It was a.
Did he fight antwan echols?
See if you find the right there.
All right.
Down there.
Antwan eccles tko 11 mm.
Maybe that was the second fight
because whoever,
whoever threw him down.
He fought him twice.
Whoever threw him down.
So it was back in the beat their ass.
Yeah,
cdc it.
What's wrong way?
Look it up a different way.
Jamie's going to look it up a different
way.
I remember seeing it on espn.
Canelo and gennady.
Golovkin though would break the bank.
Oh yeah.
Maybe go off.
Ken needs to get lIke one more big ass
fight.
He's supposed to be fun.
Danny jacobs.
Oh really?
In january and december.
There was a purse bed.
Just know.
Oh yeah.
Purse bed.
Personally.
Get.
Look at you,
you're deepen them in the boxing and the
dj world.
You know how I get down,
joe,
you do get down.
Get down buddy.
What are the good fIghts are happening
right now in boxing?
Oh,
andre ward.
Andre ward.
Kovalev.
Yeah.
And I'm in fucking toronto that night.
God damn it.
You wanted to be there.
Live that one through.
Is that one in vegas?
Yeah.
T mobile.
I believe I'm going to cover up on that.
The good fight.
Very good fight.
I don't think,
uh,
I don't think andrea has the power to
hurt kovalev do you think it's because
he's going up to 75?
One 75 and to me it's not.
Look that impressive.
And once every five we only had one
fight at one 75 to two at two.
Oh,
I thought he just had one and uh,
he doesn't hit very hard.
Who do you find it?
One 75.
Before that I found a dominican guy waS
at that fight and that was in on
ontario,
California.
And uh,
I don't know,
maybe that was at one 68,
but whatever it was,
he,
he's fought twice now.
Yeah.
It's hard when a guy has to figure out
what to do to order to make the big
bucks and you've got to take a chance.
And andrea is dominating.
It's 68.
He's just such a good boxer,
man.
They're smart dude.
You know,
he fought a bIg portion of his career
with a fucked up shoulder.
I did not know that.
Yeah,
he had to get fucked up.
I or something.
I don't know about that,
but he had to have been.
The shoulder is getting mixed up with xy
maybe.
But he finally had shoulder surgery like
two years ago.
He had to take a full,
almost like a full year off.
Yeah.
He took a lot of time off shoulder
surgeries like that.
He,
he's had a lot of years off.
He keeps getting too much time off.
As far as I'm concerned.
I mean inferior like a mean boss.
I am.
If you're at the concern as far as I'm
concerned that if you have the primary I
Korea,
you need to be in the primary career.
Yeah,
but if you got a jack shoulders,
not goddamn thing you can do about it.
True little rotator cuff.
Never hurt.
Nobody heard.
A lot of people they boxers.
It's really common.
They get shoulder injuries,
but I'm from overextending from modern
things,
just sparring and I know guys that have
had their biceps torn off because there
were sparring and they threw a punch and
someone blocked the punch,
like an got in the way and just the full
extension being caught like halfway and
then pop.
TheY got a torn bicep tendon and that's
why I don't know guys.
Well,
if you do a lot of curls,
you really should be careful because you
can break that thing and when it breaks
it pulls up and not like you never seen
matt serra's harm.
No.
That's hers.
Got one bicep that broke and then curled
up.
They can't fix it.
Well,
they could have right after it happened.
Like if you go to the hospital right
after it happened,
they reattach it and then you could fix
it.
It's like an achilles tear almost.
When your achilles snaps here,
doesn't your ankle just go loose like
that up like a rubber band?
Well,
it's like that in a way,
but apparently it just looks bad.
Like iT pulls up and it hangs up there
and it looks bad,
but it doesn't really affect the
movement of your arm.
so a lot of guys don't do anything about
it and they just didn't even get it
fixed.
They just leave it with that weird
lumping.
It doesn't,
it's got to hurt on some level.
Um,
no,
I guess it doesn't,
not according to matt serra,
you know.
Well he's the terror.
He is the terror.
But um,
you know,
there's,
there's not a goddamn thing in the world
that beats your body up more than mma
and maybe football.
She knows two thinGs.
I would much rather watch mma.
FooTball,
I don't understand football on any day.
It's because you canadian,
you're luckier here.
Luckily we let you in.
I know,
I,
you know,
I really.
Where's that?
Oh,
where's sarah?
Is that it?
Yeah,
you can see he's missing a chunk of his
arm,
his bicep,
his right bicep.
It's like the front part of it from the
elbow towards the shoulder.
My bicep.
Yeah.
I just got a chunk torn out of it,
but it doesn't affect his movement,
you know?
It's weird.
It just looks odd,
but that's a.
That's one that breaks.
The human body is very fucking soft when
it comes to the of the durability of
animals and they see how fucking goddamn
flimsy.
We are.
Russell peTers,
they've got it figured out.
Animals.
Do you think figured it out?
They figured out how the.
They know exactly how to stay in their
lane.
Yes.
they definitely do that.
Humans that are always like,
well,
there's no renaissance animals.
There should be who didn't know
everything.
You know,
they,
they can fly.
They know how to swim like a water.
The renaissance and yeah,
give a hoot.
I was a fucking creeps man.
I remember when I first moved to
California and island,
they're super violent.
Well,
they're predators.
Yeah.
When I first moved to California,
I saw an owl that was flying off with a
rabbit and dropped the rabbit and a
because I was,
you know,
he had killed his rabbit,
I guess real close to the road and as I
was driving he tried to fly off with the
rabbit and then decided,
fuck this,
I'm not getting away fast enough and
just drop the rabbit and then flew.
SO I see him fly off with the rabbit and
his talents and then go fuck this and
just release it and then boom,
the rabbIt hits the ground.
So I get out of my car and look at the
rabbit and the rabbit is just
eviscerated.
he's just torn its guts out and I'm,
I'm sitting there going like,
this is not what I think of when I think
of an owl.
Yeah,
I think
I didn't even stunk.
I guess I knew they ate rats and rodents
and stuff like that,
but I didn't think they literally will
take out something that's their size.
Are they?
They don't play.
They got,
they got big old talents on them.
That's Why.
Yeah.
Be in a bad attitude.
They're fucking cunts.
I sea hawks circling my backyard a lot
lately because I have a puppy.
Oh no.
And uh,
and uh,
so what we do is when we see these,
usually it starts with one,
then you see two,
then you see three and four.
jesus.
So I get my assistant to take out his
drone and he flies it up and scare some.
Oh,
that's a good mood.
Yeah.
That's a very good move.
Aha.
You fuckers were combating,
you know that they will eat a puppy
mill.
These,
what is this macaques?
I think.
Hey,
I'm not looking at your gut monkey's
mountains.
A small island in Japan where these,
they have this relationship,
I guess where the monkeys.
They're like,
ride the deer.
Like humans would ride a horse,
shut the fuck.
Kinda like this isn't real.
It definitely is a little humping it
right now.
but this is definitely real.
I looked it up.
they,
uh,
this might not be riding around so much,
but they'll pick a like what little
ticks and shit off parasites and they
eat them.
Like they have this weird relationship
where like out to happen.
They're like,
let them run with the rumors
is crazy.
That's just macaque.
My dad's amazing.
Wow.
So what were were reading his monkey or
watching other monkey?
Dear mounting in japanese macaques.
I can't believe this man.
I thought this was fake.
This is incredible.
So,
um,
favorite rapper,
tupac macaque fall.
You motherfucker.
How dare you?
he's grooming the deer.
There's another one that I saw.
God damn it.
Now I forget what it was.
I'll just get her shit now.
The one that had to do at the monkeYs.
Oh,
baboons.
Baboons have pet dogs.
I've seen this.
Yeah.
They get dogs as poppy's.
They raised them and they keep them
around and security.
And the dogs bark if anything comes
near.
They raised them like a Wild pat.
Yes.
Deserts.
Pictures,
videos of this.
Yeah.
There's a video of it.
It's nuts.
And like the dog doesn't start thinking
it's a,
a chimpanzee or a dog.
Acts like a dog.
I go do this.
He's got him.
He,
he's like holding onto the puppy through
audio to this.
well,
it,
the video is entitled,
so he's got the little puppy,
he's holding onto it.
Oh man,
he's rough.
And the way drags that dog around.
Holy shit
called baboons rape,
kidnapping.
Raised feral dogs as pets.
Yeah,
but they literally raised them as pets.
They beat him down.
They keep them around.
they're holding onto him.
Look at sitting on him and hold it in
place.
Oh,
it's fighting against them.
It bites against him.
So he's picking it up and
forcing it to the ground.
He's holding onto its tail and he drags
it around like a toy.
Like he has no concern.
There is such a Weird animal,
man that looks like a lion fucked a
person.
No,
it doesn't.
It they're so weird.
I mean is a baboon is one of the
weirdest fucking animals you'll ever
see.
That looks like us in a transitional
stage in the evolution chart.
Almost like a branch right at one went
left,
one went right here because they have
that lion tail and that main in the
front.
Like it's a strange,
strange appearance.
I found this one dude's page.
Um,
I don't know,
uh,
his,
pages all in arabic.
I don't know what it says,
but every day is a new and I'm all
fucking off of an animal video like
every day.
And it's overwhelming and following
them.
Yeah,
see translation right there.
I don't want to know.
I don't even want to know what they're
saying,
but I think the transitions are always
off so bad.
That's actually kind of funny.
Oh yeah.
And they're never dead out that on.
I'm trying to think of what the fuck
this dude's name is,
but I,
uh,
I'll figure it out.
I'll put it up on instagram later.
But his,
uh,
the unemployment,
his page is on.
What the other day was these hyenas
tearing apart this willdabeast like guts
first miss things,
trying to get away and get out of the
water.
And these hyenas Just ripping it apart.
Guts.
Fred savage.
Oh,
it's so hard to watch.
I can't watch that stuff were so soft.
Russell peters are.
We have been here in America too much
compassion.
Well,
it's not just that we have too much
compassion.
I'm saying that it's so easy for us to
get by.
Yeah.
We don't have to worry about a hyena.
I get nothing.
My dad grew up in the jungle.
What jungle in India.
Oh,
jesus.
So literally would he hunted tigers
leopards a wild boar.
Jesus christ.
Yeah.
Your dad did that data a lot,
man.
It was born 19,
25.
So you know,
back then it was,
it's not like he would hunt them for
fun,
but yeah,
it was big game hunter.
Wow.
We have a tiger skin with a head.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
There's last one that he shot was in the
sixties when it was already.
It was already banned.
You weren't allowed to shoot tigers in.
But the,
uh,
this man manager went to a village and
was killing people in the village.
So they had asked my dad to,
can you go get this?
Can you go,
we know your family is a bunch of
hunters,
can you go get this tiger for us?
And he's like,
well,
what's in it for me?
And they were like,
we'll give you $15.
Like,
there was a lot like,
it,
it was equivalent to that.
Somebody's saying to you today,
I'll give you $15.
Whoa.
And uh,
he said,
well,
how about you keep your money?
I get to keep the skin.
So they made like an exemption and they
were like,
yeah,
because he's getting a man.
It wasn't like it was Just randomly
coming and telling you,
boy,
that's a monster here.
I'll tell you exactly how he did it.
I remember the story.
Clearly he would,
he got,
he went to where there was two trees
side by side.
So he built up a little fort in this one
tree and then he tied a bull,
a blu walks around the other tree and
then he went and sat up in the tree at
around fiVe,
6:00
in the evening and he sat there and I'm
reading magazines and stuff.
And uh,
and then he knew when the night falls
that tiger would come out.
and then as soon as the bull started
going crazy and running around the tree
a lot because he knew he was scared.
My dad was,
he had the shotgun with them,
a three or a three.
Oh wait,
I think.
And uh,
and he had his flashlight and the minute
his flashlight touched the barrel of the
gun,
it made a metal noise.
And then as soon as he did that,
the tiger looked up at him and instead
of going for the ox leap,
straight up my dad and the tree.
Oh my god,
my dad just fumbled and shot and hit him
right here in the throat.
Oh my god.
Flipped Back.
And then he,
he flashed the flashlight on his eyes to
see if they were so glossy.
Let me put another shot and just for
safety and we have that skin to the holy
shit you're done with gangster.
It's uh,
it's at my house in kits and not in my
house.
We have it in Canada and uh,
and I want to bring it here,
but I don't know if we'll be able to.
No,
I don't think you will.
Well,
you might be able to get some sort of
historical exemption.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know what paperwork I need for
it.
I guess it's hard to prove,
you know what I mean?
So
that seems like a.
Hmm.
Maybe you'd have to.
I think what happens when they find
those things and they were illegal is
they have to donate them to museums.
Yeah.
See,
I don't want to lose that.
That's family heirloom because um,
I remember reading about someone getting
arrested.
It was a long time ago.
I want to say it was like the seventies
or the eighties.
Someone got arrested with tiger skins.
They had some tiger skins that were,
uh,
obtainEd.
One of them was obtained illegally.
right.
And you know,
but it was illegally in like 1937 when
they shot it in.
This person had,
had a couple of them,
they were in trouBle because when that
happens,
if someone sells you one,
it's apparently your responsibility.
Since it's abandoned item.
Yeah,
to bRing.
You have to bring it to like somewhere
and then they have to post it or
something.
It's like you're not alloWed to possess
it.
So if you do possess it,
you can
big trouble.
No,
this was all properly gotten and
properly imported into Canada.
But what part of India did this take
place?
Um,
it was a part is a small railway village
called boron poor.
It's kind of in the middle of the
country.
Is that anywhere near the sunderbans?
Uh,
cannot confirm nor deny that
that was the subject of this documentary
I saw where they were talking about of
thE cinder benz is a very unusual
section of the river system in India
because it's very brackish from like a
long Period of tiMe.
AnD these animals apparently drink the
water and the water has a high salt
content and it was super irritable to
the tigers and he thinks they make.
That's one of the theories theY make the
tiger's more aggressive because they're
just in pain all the time from drinking
salty water and they've killed some
insane amount of people over the last
couple hundred years.
I think it's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 200 plus thousand people
have been killed by tigers in the last
couple hundred years in this area.
I remember going there when I was 11 or
12 around that age anD my dad took us.
We went to my grandmother's who was
still lived out there and uh,
he took us for a walk.
We all had to carry guns.
I was 11 walking around with a rifle.
Oh my god.
And you,
everybody had to carry a gun because you
know,
he took us to like a,
like a river and you could see fresh
tiger prints in the mud and he was like,
look,
see.
And you follow the prince and you go,
don't.
My dad was like,
don't go that way because that's where
you're going to go the other way.
Now.
Big tiger sanctuary right next to it.
We're barranquilla here's brown pour and
then I know I can't see it.
I'm sure you've seen.
Oh wow.
That's so wild.
I've never looked at that like that.
That's pretty cool.
Can you see this on youtube?
That's all console.
I know that.
That's pretty dope.
I know that area.
When I was a kid,
I'm trying to find a picture of my dad
with a.
We have some of the shots here.
Did you see that video from that wild
animal park in beiJing?
My god,
that was all I saw it on your instagram
that I was like,
what?
What was,
why did you get out of your makes you
think?
Yeah.
People just get mad or they began.
That's what you wrote and that they
were.
She mad.
She got.
She was mad and that's why she got out
of the car.
She apparently got mad at somebody in
the car.
I don't know who,
but she got out and she survived her mom
who got out to chase the tiger away
after the tiger pulled her off.
The mom got killed.
Oh,
so the one that got taken didn't get
killed?
Yup.
Oh,
woman mauled in beijing.
tiger attack to sue.
So like a tiger.
I'm sure he doesn't have insurance.
Oh my god.
She hadn't been fully a forerunner of
the dangers and left the vehicle because
she was car sick.
Well,
she was yelling at somebody.
Oh,
here we go.
We're going to have to watch it.
I see.
She was car sick bitch.
She was carjacked.
This is so crazy.
She gets out,
she storms over to the other side.
The other person gets out.
Uh,
and she's arguing,
she's like,
listen,
I'm telling you right now,
you better shut the fuck up,
bitch.
Come here.
The time we just ran out and grabbed her
dude.
And then someone else goes out after
tiger
and then a park ranger.
Yeah,
park ranger runs in there anD that's all
we see it looked.
It looked like a tiger and was the
easiest lunch I've ever had.
Tiger probably couldn't help himself.
Finally saw something they could jack
and best yet she wasn't paying
attention.
So her back was turned.
Oh yeah.
You ever see those videos of the tigers?
Like creeping up on people when they're
sitting with their back to the cage.
Crazy.
They just dive on the back of them.
That can't help themselves.
It's wHat they do.
They're being tigers.
They are being tigers.
Tigers too busy being tigers when you
don't check and tweets.
No.
I'm trying to find this picture of my
dad.
Oh,
the tiger rug,
uh,
says you have to sign a piece of like a,
a waiver that says you will knock it out
of your car once you enter the park.
And she thought it was,
wasn't that no one explained it to her.
What does she think she's doing?
Well,
she might've not been paying attention
and not knowing that stuff.
But if somebody explains it to you,
how the fuck did they just let you drive
around your own car where they have
tigers?
China doesn't give a shit,
You know?
It's just such a ridiculous,
ballsy.
They would never have that in America
with the liability insurance that people
have to carry over here in Canada.
They have a place called african lion so
far.
When I was a kid we used to go and you
drive through with your own car and
there was.
Yeah,
there was lions,
there was giraffes and monkeys would
jump on your car and fuck up your
antenna.
And there was a place like that in New
Jersey that I went to where the monkeys
would jump on your car need?
Yeah.
They'd pull people's windshield wipers
off and they were really Destructive.
But there's a big difference between
that elian.
You guys had lions.
It was called african lions for.
I don't believe I saw lion.
Do you remember the monkeys fucking up
the car and then my mom telling me that
recently when I was home that we should
take my daughter to go see african lines
of argument going in my fucking card.
African lions.
Are you kidding me?
I saw a bobcat and a bunch of moms are a
bunch of babies.
Um,
recently.
No,
no,
no.
I was in tone ranch.
We're driving on this road and this
bobcat and I think I want to say two or
three babies,
but I saw it so briefly and I knew that
it was a cat.
I saw it so briefly and the guys I was
with thought it was a cat that in my
mind I had saw I'd seen a cougar.
I'd seen a small cougar and some cougar
puppies when they explained to me that,
no,
no.
It was a bobcat.
Then I had to look into my memory and I
was like,
how much of my memory is concocted?
How much of my memory in this situation
is Just like a total falsification?
I wanted it to be.
Well,
I've just filled in the blanks,
like I knew it was a living thing.
I knew some kind of a cat and I knew it
ran awaY really quick and there was a
couple of them.
So when we said it was a cat,
I was like,
oh well that must have been a mountain
lion.
Very small mountain lion.
And I was trying to figure it out.
Bobcats are just,
uh,
they have really big pause.
Right?
And that what it is,
some of them,
I know those are links.
Links have really big pumps because they
walked through the snow.
Yeah.
Those are weird to see.
Men don't want to see one of those.
I saw one of those when I was in Canada.
Did You?
Yeah,
walk on the side of the road.
I'd Say nature of it.
I never saw whenever.
Never saw a moose.
Elan what's.
And I know,
I know.
Who are you?
I don't know who I am.
Just not like the canadian animal or is
it like a duck or something?
The goose is ours.
Is it for real?
The Canada goose?
No,
that's your animal.
I don't know.
I think that's the only one that we
identify as canadian,
but moose is definitely part of our,
uh,
our,
heritage in a way that's kind of
appropriate that you guys are the goose
and where the eagle county shitty mean
bird doesn't give a fuck.
Kills everything but can be tamed.
A eagle gimme.
Yeah,
sure.
You can get them to sit on your arm.
was trying to one of them your eyes off
the leather.
I think you have a raise them,
but people definitely raise eagles.
I'm,
it's not like you can get a regular
eagle and tame them,
but if you raise him,
I'm sure he can get them to the point
where they don't try to kill you all.
Don't like dave's house of eagles or
something.
It's such an awesome animal though.
It's just amazing that there's such a
varietY of different things.
That's my dad killed things.
That's your dad's sitting on a god
damned man eating tiger that he killed.
What a scary thing that is.
You know,
another thing about it,
they're so beautiful.
Oh yeah.
It's weird.
Like you're going to be killed by
something that's so amazing to look at.
They don't.
They always say that if tigers were in
africa,
they would be the king of the jungle.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Other way bigger.
Especially the big ones.
Bigger,
meaner.
Yeah.
They're,
they're faster.
They're like,
they're out in the next level to align.
There was a video that I watched the
other day.
Ligers real.
Yes.
Lions are real,
but laggers tend to be like docile for
some strange reason.
You don't think anybody's ever been
attacked by a lagger.
They also have some weird growth thing
going on where the whatever regulates
growth,
they,
it doesn't.
Wow.
Yeah.
It doesn't work on them.
That's a lagger.
Yeah.
There are so huge.
They're like way bigger than regular
cats.
Look at the belly on that guy though.
Yeah,
they're fucking giant.
Dude.
That's an enormous,
enormous animal.
So,
uh,
whether it's the male tiger fucks the
female lion.
I think that's how it goes.
So when that happens,
apparently the,
um,
look at that.
That's amazing.
Look.
And apparently when,
when it does happen,
the uh,
cat,
whichever side is the lie,
I don't lie to the tiger,
one of the sides is supposed to get,
it's a,
the gene for regulating growth from the
woman,
but it doesn't get it from the woman or
it doesn't get it from the man because
the man's a tiger or the man's elian,
however,
the combination works.
But because it's a male and a female,
theY are a lion and a tiger.
They make this new thing that doesn't
know when to stop growing.
So It just keeps drawing.
Yeah,
it just gives you bigger.
These are fabricated,
these are like,
well,
they think they can appear in the wild
but they don't live in the wild
together.
Two animals that are from different
parts,
different continents.
You know what I mean?
So somebody had to have put them
together at some.
Not only that,
they're not viable.
So they're,
they're hybrids and it's a hybrid.
It's not viable.
Like they can't.
It's not like a dog,
like a wolf can fuck your dog.
And those puppies are part wolf and they
could fuck a regular dog.
And there'd be no problem,
they would just keep making puppies.
It probably good for the gene pool,
but with these things,
even though a lion and a tiger probably
look more similar than a german shepherd
and a poodle,
they do,
right.
It probably looked more simply,
completely different.
They're not the same thing so that,
that baby's a hybrid.
So it was hybrid babies.
They can't reproduce so they can produce
more ligers.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So it's there one litter animals.
But like wolf dogs will.
Dogs could fuck regular dogs and they
can,
they can get fucked by regular dogs and
coyotes like crazy in my backyard and I
fucking or screaming.
They were screaming.
I ever killing something.
I'm sure there.
Interesting thing.
Those are wolves.
Yeah.
It's their actual wolves.
Skinny wolves.
Yeah.
Little tiny wolves.
They can mate with wolves.
They made with dough.
We ran into a,
uh,
a litter once when I was doing fear
factor.
We're in this really rural area where
we're doing the stunt and we ran into a
litter of coyotes and a labrador
retriever.
Coyote had,
fuck this guy's labrador retriever.
And the labrador retriever gave birth
and then the puppies were all outside
and we were trying to,
my name mangy looking,
they will remain.
She looked and it was real sad because
uh,
there were essentially feral and people
were kind of trying to rescue them and
they're trying to give them to people on
the crew and people in the crew were
like trying to get the cell phone
service so they can call friends,
see if anybody want to take them because
you realize like,
wow,
these poor little things.
Like they're just,
they're going to die out here.
But there was also the thought like,
whoa,
who wants a half coyote?
Nobody wants that.
Ain't going to Listen to you,
man.
Wiley.
That.
Yeah,
that's a wild animal.
A tricky little wild animal.
That fucking thing is not listening.
But if you had like,
a lot of people were with the lab is
like such a calm,
peaceful dog to like bounce it out.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It might be too.
I might just make a really cunty lab.
I don't know.
I'm having this guy on soon.
He's a wildlife biologist who's been
studying all the coyotes that live in a
urban los angeles.
I was a big article about it,
about this ongoing research,
but just how many coyotes live.
There's a ton of them,
is incredible.
They've infiltrated in there.
They're a part of this.
We think we'd like to think of our eco
or,
um,
our cities rather as environments that
are free of anything alive other than us
that's dangerous or anything other than
us that's a predator.
we don't,
we don't want to think that there's
some,
some thing acting as a predator in our
midst like that.
For the most part.
We,
you know,
we like to think of cities as being
barren of wildlife,
but it's not true at all.
No.
Well,
they were.
They were here before.
We were not even,
here's the thing.
They were,
but their ranges expanded there.
I'm reading a book right now called
coyote America by this guy,
dan flores.
And uh,
he was a wildlife historian,
turned author.
And you find out about the history of
the coyote.
Apparently all dogs came from north
America.
All dogs,
all candidates,
including jackals,
including a bunch of shit that's an
africa right now.
All came from north America.
All horses,
zebras.
Then all it all came from north America.
They went extinct in north America and
then we'll reintroduced later and the
coyotes are a weird.
They get around.
How don't fucking know.
I guess pangea.
I think it was when,
when the continents were all connected,
you know,
when there was a different
configuration,
but this fucking books,
amazing man talking about the history of
the coyote and how sneaky those fuckers
are.
The reason why there's so many coyotes,
they're all across every city in America
today and that wasn't the case 100 years
ago.
They've expanded their range due to
persecution.
So when anyone,
he shoots them when wolves come in and
start killing them,
when anything happens to them,
they make more babies.
They do that roll call that screaming in
the night and day when one of them's
not.
One of them's not calling back.
The females start producing more eggs.
It's crazy shit that go from having like
for offspring to like,
you know,
for,
for pups in the.
I have like 15.
Yeah.
That's pretty crazy.
You knoW?
Have you ever heard when a siren goes
by?
It sets them off?
Yeah.
I hear a siren and then fucking all of a
sudden you hear a shitload of coyotes
and like,
wow.
Have you ever heard Turkey do that?
No.
When you slammed your car door,
right?
If you're out in the woods and he
slammed your car door,
you'll hear.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
They have this instinctive reaction,
like turkeys will gobble if you make a
Turkey call,
like,
you know they have the,
they make a call like a Turkey and a
Turkey calls back,
but they'll also do it if you just
slammed a car door.
The very sensitive to sound.
They just freak out.
And when they freak out they can't
handle themselves.
What does that meet you are cooking the
other day on instagram?
Yeah.
I wasn't good.
You ever had?
No.
Do you cook?
Uh,
I,
my,
my lady coach,
she does.
I'll give you some.
I have some ell care.
Do you really?
Yeah.
I'll take a little.
I'll call them like a cow.
Fuck.
The deere made sweet,
sweet love to a deer,
but more delicious.
It's like my favorite meat.
It's really good and I'd never thought
I'd ever say this to you,
but I really Want to taste your meat and
you can't help yourself.
I can't just who you are.
You've got to accept it.
It's true.
When you were telling me about the
coyotes and you're sending her reading
the book,
what's the name of the book?
How god America.
I was like,
have you read coyote ugly stuff?
I fucking to her it me to
stop myself from saying it.
Some kids,
they don't even know a coyote.
Ugly means.
Let me explain to you a little fucks.
Coyote ugly is when someone fucked
someone that's so ugly that your arm is
underneath them.
When you wake up and you chew your arm
off lIke a coyote caught in a trap just
so that you don't have to wake them up
and deal with them.
it's true.
That's what the term coyote ugly comes
from.
Right?
That's true.
That's a brutal goddamn term that's.
I've had a few of those in my time.
Have you?
Yeah.
It's main road.
Coyotes,
some of the old road guy,
the travels.
There's some spots in this country where
you know,
you stop in and you go,
man,
I wish I could get all of you guys out
of here.
but then you talk to them and they love
it.
They're sure people love where they are.
Do you know,
I get to some spots where I'm like,
you know,
you're driving through these really
small towns and you're looking around
and I,
I always think to myself,
I wonder if I just fucking stop the car
here.
Bought a house and then never called
anYbody again.
Just lived here in this little small
town.
You know what that is?
That's a longing for nostalgia.
It is like this.
It's like you think,
and I'm going to go back to being a
regular guy.
I'm tired of being Russell Peters,
mr international.
Mr.
Well,
you know,
it's funny.
When I go to,
when I go home to toronto,
I always drive through my old
neighborhoods like uh,
the,
the three or four neighborhoods that I
did grow up and I,
I.
Do you hang your rolex out the window
with some,
you know,
I'm almost tempted.
Always tempted to knock on the doors of
the houses I lived in.
Yeah.
But I'll do it at these ungodly hour.
So it'd be really creative and he
probably drunk.
No,
no,
no.
don't drink and drive.
Yeah.
People don't Want you knocking on their
door and saying,
hey,
I used to live here.
Yeah.
You don't need more.
nice to see ya.
take it easy.
I want to just be like,
hey,
I,
I grew up in this house.
Can I,
can I just come in and look around?
Like,
no,
you fuck.
I'm hanging meat in the basement.
Can out here.
There was a house.
I was a.
I grew up in.
That was for sale recently.
I could see online.
It's weird.
Should've bought it.
No,
no.
Learn mastered in newton.
Newton,
upper falls.
What is interesting to see it did.
You knew dana back then?
No,
no,
I didn't know dana.
I didn't know dean until 2001 or
something like that.
Like whenever they bought the ufc.
Yeah,
he uh,
he lived in south boston.
I used to work in south boston at one
point over the southeaster.
yeah,
I think he lived there.
I think you said he lived in south
boston,
but I lived in newton,
newton upper falls now.
I lived all over the place.
Once I moved down to my parents' place,
I moved to in a lot of shitty
neighborhoods and pursuing my comedy
dream.
Russell peters.
I never had that accident.
I did.
I found myself on tv when I won the bay
state games in 1986 86 or 87 like that.
They had this thing called the bay state
games and it was like this big thing.
Um,
it waS his,
it was his big tournament that they
would do like an olympic style
tournament.
And um,
it was a taekwondo.
Yeah.
And they've televised this fight or they
televise.
They'd fucked up the camera in the
camera missive.
I won by knockout in the first round and
like 30 seconds and then,
um,
they had this big a tv report where they
had these,
these tv people interview me because,
uh,
I had won the state championship a
couple of years in a row and they were
interested in coverage of the bay state
games.
Anyway,
I listen to myself on tv and I sound
like such a fucking idiot.
I had a vh tape,
vhs tape myself and I realized it was
the first time I heard myself.
No,
I don't know where it is.
There's,
I never realized how canadian I sounded
until I saw an interview of mine from
like 97,
96 and I was just so earnest and,
and canadian.
I was just at the boat.
Did you say if I did,
I fucking did.
Do you don't say it anymore?
No.
Say about say about.
Yeah,
that's right.
You're troubling.
I think,
feel the struggle.
The only thing I say that's still very
canadian of.
Sorry.
Ugh.
I listen to myself when I was 19 and
this,
this video and I was saying hide like we
worked out really hard for this.
Oh.
I was like,
oh,
that's so funny to me.
He said,
oh,
well it was just counseling out there
too in boston.
Callen wasn't boston,
but again,
I didn't know him either.
Account was apparently in boston,
any was also doing taekwondo,
but I didn't know him,
but he was born in India.
Cowen was born in Philippines.
Philippines.
His sisTer was born in India.
Yeah.
He was a military child.
So he.
He lived all over the place.
He lived in Saudi Arabia.
He lived everywhere.
Fucking weird way to grow up,
man.
Yeah.
I can't imagine that living in a bunch
of strange foreign countries,
but to be like,
I mean to be as well rounded as he is
today is a testament to him.
Yeah.
Well he's super well rounded as far as
kids interests.
Yeah.
He's.
Yeah,
he's a guy.
He knows a lot of shit.
Yeah.
He knows a lot of shit about.
Very interesting in different.
Like,
he's one of the few guys that I can call
up,
like some bizarre thing that's in the
news,
I can call.
Hey,
I'm filming on this,
like what the fuck's going on with this?
And he'll,
he'll be able to most likely have some
insight.
He's kinda like a pretty broad range of
topics in his head that he knows quite a
bit about like don't ever talk to him
about wine.
You'll get stuck.
Oh yeah,
I can drink wine.
I got acid reflux,
no wine for me.
What has acid reflux to your body
telling you you're a fat fuck and you
need to change your diet.
Is that what it is?
But what does it mean?
Does it mean like you,
like you burps come up?
Um,
bert burns just burns to here.
So your digestive juices kicked back up?
Yeah.
You.
Oh,
it's horrible.
But you know,
I'm must constantly.
I've had it since I was a kid,
so you know,
since I was,
I remember being a six,
seven year old having it now.
Is there anything,
there was no.
What?
Did they give you?
Something for it back then?
No,
now now,
yeah,
I take a stuff called protonix.
And what does that stuff do?
Um,
it just stops it.
I don't know what it does exactly,
but I know I don't feel any pain when
I'm on it.
So I'm good with it.
You don't feel any pain,
like you can whack your deck with a
hammer if that kind of thing.
So I'm numb,
numb to the world,
to the world.
That's what you look at.
Pizza and not worrying.
I drank a whole mountain dew.
I don't give a fuck.
Do you think there's a dietary?
Absolutely.
When I cue and I eat properly,
it doesn't bother me at all.
I could not take medication then.
That'S interesting.
So you choose to eat like shit.
So you know,
I just do it.
I do it preventatively now.
Uh,
just in case I don't know what the
fuck's going to trigger it.
Wow.
So when it triggers that,
it just kicks in and you start getting
that burning feeling like it's kind of
like a.
Yeah,
it's like a burn in your eye.
You're burping your eyes,
water and like we'll do it to you.
Like lasagna,
lasagna,
kick you down?
No pizza would take me down.
Pizza,
french fries for anything greasy
recently.
A wine is the worst for me though.
Really?
Oh my god.
Right now we busted out a glass of wine.
Started clinking glasses.
you just start throwing up.
No,
no,
no.
It wouldn't hit me.
I'd feel I'd be like,
oh,
it's all right now.
And then when I go to bed the minute I
lay down.
Oh,
that's what you feel like.
Shit.
That's when it happens,
man.
Stay up.
That's what I'd say.
I'd just rather don't be a pussy.
Don't know.
I'm not committing to this more.
Yeah man.
You just got to keep partying bro.
I don't know.
Side effects.
Can you see what the side effects to
protonix are?
Because I'm pretty sure you got to have
some.
I heard probably short term memory.
I forget why I was a pilot lady.
That was the.
What was that shit?
Shit.
How would you categorize that?
If you're a professional weight changes.
See when he changes.
Vomiting,
diarrhea,
stomach pain.
Tired feeling of it's always to get off
this stuff.
Okay.
Jamie now google protonix dangers.
Please god me longterm use may cause
issues.
Do get off that shit.
Oh my god.
What are you taken?
Common side effects.
Fda sounds alarm on the dangers of
antacid drugs.
Please.
If it's what you take to fix it,
click click on quick.
Chris crushers.
Article.
Fda sounds,
alarms and dangers of asperger's six
years ago.
This guy is smart as fuck I had him on
the podcast.
Very,
very knowledgeable guy.
God damn your popups.
Fuck your popups.
So what does it say here?
In a shocking,
shocking,
rare example of fda actually doing its
job or for a report was issued on
tuesday,
cautioning against the prolonged use of
a class of acid stopping drugs called
proton pump inhibitors.
Okay,
so this is the shit band.
Oh my god.
American spend five
point $1,000,000,000
on the most popular anti acids that is
saying,
holy shit,
there's so much money in drugs.
That's what we should have got into.
Russell.
Why are we.
Why are we telling jokes?
We can be selling drugs lower.
You're busy taking them.
So why don't why I take the good ones?
What's it?
That stuff though,
doesn't seem like a good one.
And you take that stuff.
Take it to day,
dude.
Stop taking that place and to take it
when I wake up and I'd take it before I
go to bed.
Can I connect you with a diet guy that
could change your life?
Yes.
Would you do it?
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to connect you with a guy.
I know a guy that can change your life.
Yeah.
I need that.
Change your la live changing lives.
Would you listen?
Would you only eat the stuff that he
told you to?
If he.
Yeah,
I mean if I'm not an expert so I would
have to listen to what he says.
Now you're a wealthy man.
How come you haven't already done this?
Um,
I,
I do.
I try to paper.
You got to have a try.
I try.
I,
I just enjoy food.
I enjoy listening to man.
I was the problem.
I'm like,
you know what?
I feel like going off sometimes.
Maybe right now like going and getting
like a gigantic fucking mushroom
pepperoni pizza.
Not give a fuck about what you just did.
You plant that seed in my head just
perfect right off the fucking oven.
They slide it out of that oven with that
giant bachelor and they drop it down to
that box.
The drop him like a ton.
He just start pulling slices apart and
that cheese is hanging you all gooey and
you dig and taste tomato sauce and that
grease and the spices and you're just
chilling on the carbs too and you're
just going,
fuck yeah.
Like I don't need a six pack.
I don't need to be shredded.
Fuck all that kimmy,
this pizza right now.
That's my problem.
That's a problem.
The problem is the way you sold it just
now.
It may stop on the way home.
Yeah.
I hate a bunch of boring shit today.
All right.
I ate nuts.
Eggs ate a bunch of boring ass shit.
I certainly didn't have a fresh pizza.
my head multigrain cheerios.
That's good.
If you like sugar and things that aren't
really good for you,
but appear to be good for you on the
box.
Multigrain,
they were delicious.
You know what I like?
Pineapple and anchovy pizza you've ever
had like pineapple on.
Uh,
on,
on intro.
Rosanna.
See the two of them together.
I know it seems nasty.
I know people are listening to me.
They like joe.
You to mask the anchovy.
It doesn't mask.
It gets busy together telling you it's
fantastic.
I mean I can't do country smelling
thing.
Not only that I go double pineapple.
Double anchovy.
Yeah.
Can't do that.
Give a fuck.
You're just shit on my pizza.
Dreams that.
Guess what?
You just talked me out of eating pizza.
So it was another one.
Maybe this be more up your alley.
Jalapenos and sausage?
No.
See the triggers for me.
Oh,
don't be a pussy or taking drugs.
I knoW if it's on your lap and l's and
they take care of the animal all.
Fuck me sideways.
And extra medicine.
Can you take like four of those fuckers
didn't want to do that.
Now what happens?
I don't know yet.
No more ass lying down and cleans out
all your assets.
What's happening?
Like what is it?
How's it stopping that?
I don't know.
What's it doing it good.
But if you had it since I was a kid and
my parents were just telling me drink
milk.
Hm.
That's a good thing to tell people.
My mom was like,
go drink.
Some milk will go away.
It's almost like nothing you should
drink milk for other than,
than you want milk and drinks.
Milk.
It'll cool down.
Well,
indians evan,
because despite foods or spicy,
they serve a yogurt dish with it and
yogurts to.
Oh,
okay.
To calm.
You're calm everything down.
And I never liked the yogurt as a kid so
I would have to just drink milk.
I went to a kid's party recently and uh,
we uh,
we pulled up and it was this thing at
this roller skating place and I'm hungry
and I was like,
I gotta get something to eat,
find something.
Yeah.
So right around the quarters is just
like super authentic indian,
like deli slash,
like lunch place where everything was in
indian and everything was.
There was a few things that were in
english.
No one there was american except for me
or no one.
There was a,
you know,
your standard english speaking person,
except for me.
No one knew what the fuck I was saying
like I was like,
had to tell this lady that didn't want
the nan bread and she just wanted given
it to me anyway.
Yeah.
But it was.
The food was sensational.
It was really good.
All vegetarian indian food,
but I really felt like I had somehow or
another like teleported into another
country.
I waS hanging out with these people.
They're all wearing indian clothes,
clothes that would totally identified
them as being from India.
Everything was in.
They had indian music playing.
Indian tv shows it.
Sometimes they went deep,
they missed the motherland,
liKe a time capsule,
but the food is so distinct.
it's like all the curries and the
different spices and the tumeric and
it's a really interesting type of food
man.
It depends on which part of India you
are eating food from two very different
everywhere.
There's a place on south east,
west.
Everybody has their own stuff.
Yeah.
There's a place on ventura.
Where's the.
Where's the best indian restaurant in
la?
Is there a one spot that I used to go to
in studio city called.
It used to be called great India cafe
and they just changed the name and I
forgot what the change the name to,
but the restaurant's still there.
There's one in.
It's pretty damn good.
Woodland hills on ventura.
That's really good.
I might have been to that one under
barack or something like that.
Down closer to the one on one area.
Yes.
Closer to like calabasas.
Yeah.
I think that place is really good.
A little strip plaza.
Yeah.
I mean it's not bad to me.
It's really good.
I don't
know.
Shit though.
I want.
I want you to school me in the ways of
the authentic.
My mom taught my fiance.
How do I make her food her way?
And she makes it fucking amazingly.
So,
uh,
if you're into it,
I will.
Have you have you in wifey over.
Let's do it.
Come on.
Um,
there was the place that I went to that
I told you that was super authentic
indian,
but it was all vegetarian.
Is that common?
Yes,
because there'S a sagittarius is big
over there.
The second place that I've found that's
like a super authentic,
uh,
there's another one in canoga park
that's real similar.
It's like a,
like a super market
rather than.
And then they also serve food there,
but it's all vegetarian is more common
than not in India really,
you know,
you have to specify they'll,
they'll put on the outside vege and non
vege.
So why don't airplanes when they order
their food and then they screw it up.
Um,
I am,
I am a vegetable and my wife is also a
vegetable.
oh,
that's what they say.
Yeah.
So that's true.
But it's good to hear.
Why is that that indian so predominantly
vegetarian.
I'm just alwayS has been historically.
I mean,
you know,
they,
I think they revere animals quite a bit
and they also don't have the uh,
can't really facilitate.
I'm storing meat,
you knoW?
Right.
We don't have refrigerators and stuff.
That makes sense.
It's easier to hang onto the vegetables,
but there are some dishes like a,
like there's one that has rogan in it.
lamb,
rogan,
joe rogan,
josh.
Oh yeah.
That shit is good.
That is good.
Oh my god.
That place in woodland hills.
I've had it there.
Extra spicy.
Oh my god.
Joe says damn good.
You say josh does josh.
Josh,
yeah.
Yeah,
but that's a meat dish.
Is that is just a small amount of thoSe
meat dishes?
Yeah.
No,
no.
There's a lot of meat dishes.
It's just,
you know,
more often than not you'll find,
you'll find it's probably easier to find
a vegetarian indian restaurant than it
would be to find a meat one.
I wonder if,
unless you go from like north India,
north indians tend to eat a lot more
meat.
One,
if there's a direct connection.
I mean India has always had like an
issue with Pakistan.
They'd been involved in conflicts
before.
But overAll when people think about
indian people,
people from India,
they think of them as not being like
war,
like to think of being.
It's being pretty peaceful people.
I wonder if there's a correlation
between that and the massive amount of
people you plants only.
I'm a wonder.
I don't know.
it's a possibility.
They are,
uh,
very,
you know,
there have alwayS been big on meditating
and yoga obviously is ours and yeah.
And centering yourself and eating hash
eating hash
when you go deep,
deep,
deep into the records.
They had some really crazy ancient
writings,
man on vmr news,
this flying saucer talk and shit.
And some of the sand skirts.
The anger of all
european languages.
Is it [inaudible]
from a pretty cool place,
huh?
That's not too shabby.
It's pretty bad ass.
Have you started thinking about all the.
No.
Oh,
you'd love it.
All the cool shit that's been from
India,
like that's a very unique part of the
world.
Yeah.
I think you'd really enjoy it out there.
You got to get rid of those tigers for.
I go visit.
Not into that.
Your dad can do that.
I'm not,
not going to be there for that for the
time.
I used to have this bit in my act about
a,
a real thing that happened on the soon.
Depends wHere this tiger jumped into the
river,
swam up to a boat that had five
fishermen in it and killed one at a
time.
Killed three guys,
grabbed them,
bid them,
drag them into the water,
pulled him to shore,
killed him,
jumped back in the water,
swam back out to the boat,
grabbed the next guy,
pulled him to shore,
and these guys thought about they
couldn't do anything.
They were trying to row.
They couldn't roll fast in the entire
swim.
They swam faster than five guys can row
and then then for grad can row and then
three gaskets,
rail.
So it's two guys left,
two guys survived on three out of the
five were killed by the same fucking
tiger who's kept swimming out to the
boat and jacking them and then swimming
to shore with them,
you know,
to him it was like being at a party and
the order of trade was coming.
I'll get another one of those police.
He chased it down with a 10 or third
when he was like,
you know,
I really shouldn't,
but oh,
I really wish I saved that video of the
tiger running at the guy because it
turns off at the last minute.
I think they fire a gun and scare it,
but it's running at him at an impossible
rate of speed.
Like you see it running.
He just,
it forces your brain to reprocess how
fast you can get out of the way.
Like I think we like to think like,
oh,
if something's coming at me,
bro,
a fucking get out of there.
I run so fast here.
I,
you know,
I always think about like a dog or
something or even if a coyote came at
me,
I'm like a punch in the face.
It's not just going to sit there and let
you punch it in the face.
You know,
you start,
you started,
your tough guy kicks in and then your
reality kicks back in,
you know,
well that's what people think they could
do to each other too.
You know?
Guys are always thinking,
yeah,
this fucking goes looking at you.
I saw him looking at you.
I'm just going to go over there.
Fuck a guy up and you think in your
head.
I got a plan here and I'm going to say
something that I'm going to hit it with
one of these and that's going to be the
end of that and then when it's not,
when the guy moves his head and hits you
with a jab and kicks you in the balls,
you're like,
oh no.
What have I done?
Always.
Then you get beat up by his friends,
but you have in your head you have this
thing that tiger's going to run at me
and I'm going to get the fuck out of the
way.
Like the guys that tried to fight nick
diaz and the guy in the bathroom.
Yeah.
What a great idea.
Fucking smart plan.
Stupid.
In the next time you're going to mouth
off to someone to look at their ears
first.
Let's just look in his eyes,
man.
Just get scar tissue all over his
eyebrows.
Wouldn't you just assume that that guy
has been into wild?
They're just drunk dummies.
You got a lot of those in this world.
Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
Even when I'm drunk,
I'm not that stupid and that's why
you're Russell Peters,
you not one of those dummies.
We need those guys to russell.
It's true that we need to balance out
the ecosystem for now.
We've just got to raise the level of
dummy,
you know,
because the level of dummy today,
if you take the average jami,
like even those guys that got in a fight
with nick diaz,
we take those guys and drop them off in
the caveman days.
They'd be running shit to be the
smartest guy in the room.
They'd be able to take.
Listen,
listen,
you guys don't know shit.
You don't know what you're doing.
First of all,
we got to make some shelter.
We can't rely on this cave.
The bears know where the cave is.
Okay,
come on guys.
Come with me.
They'd figure out tools like you guys
haven't even figured out tools yet.
We gotta make foreman's.
they'd be the performance.
You could get one of those dummies and
bring them back to the point before.
Monkey peopLe invented tools and he
could start making tools.
He'd be the king.
Right?
Well,
that's.
That's what's happening.
It's just.
That was only a million years ago.
So evolution is not like all of a sudden
now we're at point 10.
No,
there's still people at point six that
guys at point six,
that's whatever.
People really think.
Evolution is a even playing field.
Everyone's like,
well then how come I'm like,
because you're an idiot.
That's why it's an even playing field.
While people don't want to admit that,
that life isn't fair,
you know,
in,
in a bunch of different ways.
It's definitely not fair physically have
you think it's fair to fair physically
go,
try wrestling.
Lebron james.
Just grab them.
Just want to feel helpless.
You are just feel,
feel what it feels like if a fucking nfl
lineman grabs you by your neck,
just feel,
feel how vulnerable you actually are in
relationships.
How you appear that you are or how you
think that you are.
Yeah.
What you envisioned for yourself.
This is more align.
Fair at all.
People have that.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
what's,
what's the fucking word?
I'm looking for with her,
the way they,
the way they see themselves as not
really the way they are.
You know when I look in the mirror,
I still see a 25 year old Russell
Peters,
but then when I get honest with myself,
I got the fuck happened there kid.
You got to stay drunk and stay drunk and
keep moving.
Sometimes that's the answer.
A lot of people will tell you,
introspection,
yoga tank,
you can go that way or stay drunk and
keep moving.
Like I love people to do both.
Like let's stand hopes.
One of my favorites stays drunk.
Keeps moving.
Same with hunter thompson.
Stayed drunk,
kept moving.
You still got your isolation tank?
Yes,
I do often want to go in it.
I do when I really do say the word.
Any you tell me whenever you're home.
Come on over,
dude.
We'll make it happen.
You're not far from me.
Know.
We'll make it happen.
Dude.
It's you.
You'll love it.
So relaxing and you get out of.
There you go.
Whoa.
That's it,
huh?
Yeah.
That's it.
I really want to do.
It.
Feels real good.
Loosens up everything.
Yeah.
I need that just to shut off.
Shut off the world.
Do you have a spot in your house where
you can put one?
Um,
no.
No.
Can you go?
Can you build a little shack?
I could,
yeah.
Should do that.
Just going to wait until I move and then
I'll do it because then I'll have a man
cave that I can.
Another man can.
Yeah.
You want.
Ideally the best move would be if you
had a bathroom that you could sacrifice.
If you had a house.
I know you're a baller so you're going
to get a nice house if you have a house
and you could sacrifice one of your
bathrooms.
Set it up in there so that you have the
shower that's right there.
It's already set up for plumbing and all
that jazz and I have like the guys from
float lab set it up.
You will value it so much.
It's so.
It's such a nice place to just chill and
think about shit and reflect.
How long do you do it?
The least I do is an hour usually,
but I will jump in if I only have 40
minutes and I said I just want to get in
there right now.
I'll,
we'll jump in and do like 40 minutes if
I know I have to go somewhere.
But honestly that is contrary to what
it's good for.
What it's good for is like the end of
the day for me.
Like everybody's asleep and I can get in
that thing.
I can just
just totally removed myself.
Do you fell asleep in there?
No,
never.
I don't think so.
Maybe when a jerk I don't do that.
um,
but the salt gets us.
Thanks.
Um,
you can for sure.
I have a hard time falling asleep laying
on my back though because I got sleep
apnea.
So if I,
you know,
I know snore like a motorcycle now.
Yeah,
it's super common.
Super common.
A lot of people have it really fucks
with your sleep man.
Should do somethIng about that.
Sometimes I'll take an advil cold and
sinus if I go to bed to help.
Yeah.
Because it opens up my airways.
So you want them to take a pill guys?
Huh?
not really.
Actually we got to fix you.
This is what we're going to do with god.
Damn it.
First of all,
no working out with that manny pacquiao.
Train anymore.
Guys,
get a break.
You need to go to equinox and get a
goddamn regular training.
Like a gentleman.
I just want to get small.
He was making me big.
I got like,
I was way healthier,
I guess.
I don't know.
But uh,
you know,
and now when I laugh I could feel my
core is really good in there.
But there's a lot of shit on top of this
core right now.
Well,
I can help you with that.
I got to go.
I'm going to connect you with,
with that.
If you follow his diet,
it will without a doubt.
Clean you up.
We're going to make that happen.
Russell peters,
a lady loves to cook for me.
So she'll cook whatever we tell it,
man.
It's going to be hard though.
The real way to get your body to lose
weight is you got to get off the fucking
carbs and the sugar.
Yes.
Those are the most addictive things in
the world.
I know.
The key is don't torture yourself
relentlessly like every now and then
you've got to give yourself a break.
Give yourself a little reward.
When I was training with a raise,
I would get a one day treat cheat day.
Yeah,
I would go fucking nuts on that day
though.
What'd you have to have?
Pizza.
I would go to.
I went to tommy's,
I had chili cheese fries and a double
cheeseburger.
So like,
this is an one day,
you know,
I was going in cake,
ice cream.
I went in on everything,
you know my friend eddie bravo.
Right?
And of course when eddie bravo used to
be on the atkins diet and then he went
from the atkins diet everY day too,
who would have like a sunday and sunday
would be as cheat day.
And Then sunday started,
started kicking in around saturday at
midnight.
That's it.
And so then he saId,
well fuck it man.
If it's saturday at midnight,
why don't I just do the whole weekend?
I don't want to.
I don't want to worry about this.
Let me start.
I'll start it,
I'll,
I'll start the cheat day on friday,
so he went friday,
so it was basically four days atkins,
but when he did one day,
when he did one day,
he was legendary with what he would
throw down.
I mean he would eat stacks of fucking
pancakes.
He would eat bowls of ice cream,
cheese,
burgers,
pizza.
He would go off,
I mean just go off and he would do it
with such lust,
like a guy who had been depriving
himself for six days.
Exactly how it was.
It was.
It was very therapeutic.
Like what is the most disgusted you ever
felt yourself on a cheat day?
Oh,
I did.
It was.
That was the first cheat days when I
went in because I went to ihop for
breakfast and had the country fried
steak with scrambled eggs and cheese and
then I had the pancakes and then later
on I had pizza as a snack.
Oh my god.
When I had went to tommy's,
because like,
because five guys was too far because I
really wanted five guys.
I'd say,
dude,
I had chicken fried steak in Montana
where they really know how to make it
like rancher style with the country
countries.
No.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's just so good though.
It was a glorious cheat meal.
It was smothered in this,
this delicious gravy.
See,
you don't get that from healthy food.
No,
I know.
You don't get that feeling.
There's just a crazy car billowed
feeling that you get.
It's a.
It's a weird warmth.
it's a good warmth.
A bowl of spaghetti with meatballs,
like when you're sucking down that
fan of the fettuccine alfredo with
chicken and they usually use pen a
noodles because I don't want to be
slapped in the face with fucking
fettuccine [inaudible].
That's a good move.
That's a good move as well.
I'm particularly fond of linguine with
clams,
with white sauce.
Done correctly.
No,
ken defend.
There's no takedown defense to the
linguine with clams.
You know what else is really good,
man?
I'm lobster fried diablo with linguini.
I do not know this.
Oh my goodness.
Your appetite and you know,
three quarters,
one quarter,
irish.
Uh,
yeah.
It's a spicy spicy tomato sauce with
lobster and spaghetti,
jesus christ,
Russell Peters.
It's so.
I think you're going to have a cheat day
to day gather with garlic bread and you,
uh,
you,
you put some parmesan cheese on top of
it.
JusT some grated parmesan on the top of
that bitch.
God damn,
that's so good.
People tell you they,
you never should put cheese on.
Like if you get linguine with clams,
they tell you not to put the cheese on.
And oftentImes if you go to a proper
italian restaurant won't give it.
They get mad at you.
If you try to put cheese on that
linguine clam sauce,
those people are assholes.
They don't know shit.
Attends clams,
protective of the way things are done in
toronto.
The italians are first generation,
so everyBody speaks italian and they are
very italian and I love italian
sandwiches and they get so mad when I
walk into the fucking italian store,
they're happy to see me at first.
Hey.
And then I picked the bread and then
like,
what do you want on it?
I go,
ah,
no.
I go,
you're going to get mad.
I need butter on the bread.
Thank you.
And then I go and then,
then I picked the mates and they're
like,
all right,
that's it.
And I go,
can I get some manet's on that?
Oh for fuck's sake.
You want me to shit on the bread,
but I get so mad.
They literally asked me if you want me
to shit on your sandwich too because
you're fucking it up kid.
Well how can they do that when they're
asking you what,
what they lock on it.
That's one way.
Subway superior.
So it is not giving you a hard time for
your choices.
You know,
you could just say salami with hot
peppers.
They're like,
okay.
And that's white subway.
Not a subway old guy.
But uh,
Kevin James and I went to this italian
restaurant once and we both wanted
linguine with clams,
with the cheese and it was like a big.
You can ask for the cheese.
I'm going to ask for the cheese.
Okay.
I'll ask for the cheat if you asked for
the jeans because they don't want to
give it to you.
They want to give you the linguine with
clams and if you have a dish training
with eddie,
kevin,
james.
Uh,
no,
not right now.
Why?
I know he was training for a bit.
Then he's done a lot of training with
bas rutan.
Oh,
that's right with boss.
And he did some stuff with ray longo.
Kevin's actually really accomplished
martial artists.
He's actually,
he's got really good hands.
Very good kicks.
Like he's a real martial artists,
you know,
he's a big guy but he,
he can fucking hit hard.
Like it's kind of surprising if you ever
see him hit the bag or a hit the pads
with mark [inaudible].
It's pretty impressive.
Like,
you know,
he doesn't look like a professional
fighter,
but he's a very confident and competent.
Rather a martial artist but didn't want
to ask for that cheese.
Needed a got to keep that she's coming.
But if you were right next to me and it
was in red sauce and meatballs,
they would offer you the cheese cheese.
So you would make somebody ordered that
oN the side.
Just know you.
You would be right next to me and he
would offer you the cheese and they
would walk away and I'd be like,
what about me?
And like,
sir,
we do not recommend the cheese for this
because it will be two delicious.
Yeah,
if you wouldn't be able to handle it.
We don't want you to euphoria.
Well,
they have very specific taste that you
want to take in.
They want you to take in the taste of
the noodles,
the olive oil spices and the clams.
That's perfection.
Take it in.
Take it in like that.
Like,
nah,
I need to add my own perfection to this
perfection cheese on this motherfucker.
You got to catch up on my daughter.
My daughter loves the cheese too,
so she'll be like,
when I make her a little pasta,
she was like,
daddy,
can I put the cheese?
And then she it and dumps it on their
kids.
Love cheese tastes good.
It's rewarding you.
Some sort of weird lactose way.
It's giving you some weird,
very slow trouble helping the bones was
supposedly right.
Calcium,
but cheese.
Cheese is way better when it's raw.
You remember raw cheese?
No,
I have not.
I've been getting into rochester herds.
You made now raw.
He's like,
get cheese from place that uses raw
milk.
Um,
I've been getting into that and drinking
raw milk.
Been drinking a lot of raw milk lately.
You'd only goat's milk.
I'm not have,
I have drinken raw goat's milk,
but no,
you just raw cow's milk.
You can get it from some,
some sustainable farms and um,
some like erewhon gary's cold though,
right?
Yeah.
Tastes delicious.
Dude.
It's so much better.
It goes down easier.
Like regular milk feels weird and one of
the reasons why regular milk feels
weird.
It's because it's homogenized and
pasteurized and apparently there's
enzymes in milk that when you're boiling
the milk to treat it and make it sort of
lasts longer and so it doesn't have any
ds and you're killing all the good stuff
too.
So your body is drinking this weird
liquidy protein.
It doesn't exactly know what to do with
like during chemotherapy on milk because
everything,
a lot of it.
Yeah.
In a lot of ways it is,
yeah,
it's just boiling the fuck out of it.
But when you don't have it that way,
when you just have cold,
raw milk,
it's way better.
It tastes better.
It feels smooth when it goes down.
So one thing that people,
uh,
um,
comment on when they drink it,
they're like,
wow,
it's really smooth.
Like,
because it's got all the stuff that
you're supposed to drink and people tell
you you're not supposed to drink milk.
No.
They taste a little different.
His better to me.
To me,
I think it tastes better.
I mean some people,
like some people like low fat milk.
I think that shit's disgusting.
I'd rather just drink water or low fat
milk tastes weird and coffee.
I like to put half and half.
I like that too.
This is getting to a.
What do I like show?
I do like mason.
Welcome to the joe rogan experience
where we're talking about coffee and
things.
We liken it back when there was a
milkman delivered milk everyday,
whether it had been fucking your wife.
that's what I was doing.
I said,
well,
that's the big milk,
because they had to do it all the time
because it was 100 percent raw mouth
probably.
I wonder when they came up with the
homogenization process,
imagination,
once they did come up with the
pasteurization.
That's louie pastor.
You got to find it.
That's interesting.
I wonder how much of that was raw and
how much of it was pasteurized when they
started doing that on a big scale,
but it's.
It's imperative if you want to like keep
it on the shelf,
like you're not going to be able to keep
raw milk on the shelf for very long
because I've had it in my house for just
a couple of days and it noticeably goes
bad in the refrigerator.
Not bad where you can't drInk it,
but to wear it.
It's like,
wow,
this is on the door of getting funky
text after text my ex wife because I got
to pick up my daughter.
What do you got there?
Jamie found that weird milk milestones
of milk history of us in 1950 there was
milk vending machines.
Whoa.
When did they start?
Okay,
find out.
There's a lot of first compulsory
pasteurization law in chicago applying
the milk,
except that except that from to burke.
Kulin tested cows 19.
Oh,
eight
tuberculin hm.
What Is that?
Is that,
is that tuberculosis?
Brucellosis.
Is that brucellosis is.
Brucellosis is something that cows get
that I know.
Um,
it's like,
uh,
one of the main concerns about a
different wildlife populations mingling,
especially buffalo,
like some buffalo have brucellosis and
they can get it to cows.
So 19,
19 and milk was sold successfully for
the first time in Connecticut.
And then a couple more years passed by
before.
Uh,
let's see.
First farm belt,
first farm bulk tanks for milk began
replacing milk cans in 1938.
And then every other day milk delivery
started in 42 and then it was added to
school lunches and 46.
Yeah.
But when It was in 42 is that
homogenized and pasteurized milk when
they started initially as a conservation
measure,
I wonder if they do it every day and you
have an ice box in your house,
you probably don't have to.
That's kind of crazy though.
They relied on a guy to come by with a
milk,
like that's how everybody got their
milk.
Also,
people's lifespans.
Life expectancies were a lot shorter
back then.
It was.
So is this a good thing or bad thing
that we did?
Um,
they were shorter than.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Well,
let's.
Because people dIdn't understand
medicine or vitamins.
True target.
Nineteen 30.
They just knocked you over the head
with.
They had to do surgery when he was a
kid.
No way for real.
Yeah.
No,
not scurvy or ricketts.
He had rickets,
rickets.
Where does that come from?
I don't know.
Nutrition or something.
He's had it when he was a baby and then
a stunted his growth.
So you only became like five.
I was tallest.
Maybe five,
three,
five,
four.
I think when we get older in our
lifetimes,
there's gonna come a point in time where
they,
they laugh at people being sick or
people being injured.
I think they're gonna be able to repair
our bodies perfectly.
They're gonna be able to regenerate
limbs within the next 50 a hundred
years.
It's probably going to be so many crazy
advancements to medical science.
We're going to look back on injuries and
the treatment of injuries,
the way we do it today,
you know,
that's,
I think,
you know,
once they get the stem cells shit.
Right.
Have you had any of that yet?
No.
I,
you know,
when I was in India last year on tour,
this guy gave me some,
um,
like a face stuff that gives you a
facial.
Yeah.
He was really friendly and I just stood
there always some sort of oil to rub on
my face that had stem cells in it.
probably bullshit.
yeah.
And he was like,
oh,
you're gonna.
See it's gonna have an immediate effect.
and they call me bro,
I love to do business with you.
and then I did it for like two months
and I was like,
nope.
Nothing.
All it did was give
me a couple of pimples.
It's with it.
Yeah.
It's probably bullshit,
man.
The real stem cell shit,
they're going to inject in you.
They have to keep it cold.
It's.
Yeah.
I didn't,
didn't,
didn't do anything for me.
We're going to be,
I think the first group of people to see
people live like deep into the hundreds.
I think it's going to be real weird.
Like what is a 200 year old healthy
person going to be like,
how strange is it going to be if they're
really figure out a way to regenerate
tissue and keep someone in a relatively
healthy state and you get to see like
the wisdom of someone that's two,
300 years old.
He's like,
you're 40.
What'd you say?
Over 46.
40 six.
How much smarter you than when you were
26.
Whole lot.
Lot,
right?
Hold that.
If you live to be 146,
how much smarter would you be?
pretty good.
Now,
as long as you're coherent.
What if you looked exactly the same?
That'd be pretty awesome.
That'd be strange.
It'd be strange.
But also,
did you feel guilty if you're getting
pussy at 1:46?
Nope.
I was getting busy when I was fighting
at 1:47
back in the day.
I uh,
um,
I think if they can,
they can get the hgh thing right.
Make it cancer free.
I think that there's a possibility,
there's no correlation between hgh and
cancer.
The correlations between abuse of hgh
and some issues and also cancer with a
bunch of different factors.
Environmental factors,
factors like diet factors like heredity.
There's a bunch of different shit,
but there's a concern that if you are
supplementing with human growth hormone
and a cancer grows in your body,
that it could grow more.
that is a concern,
but I don't think there's any real
evidence to support that concern that
I've ever read.
But what's interesting about cancer that
I've been reading a lot about is when
you get your body to,
if you get your body to a place where
it's used to a bunch of different
chemicals that are,
that are in the environment,
whether it's pollutants or whether it's
uh,
you know,
and uh,
something that you work with,
like,
uh,
people that work around like really
strong chemicals.
People that work like with automotive
stuff like all the bondos and epoxies
and all that.
Like those people,
their cancer numbers.
Whenever you work with a lot of
chemicals and cancer numbers get crazy
high,
like that seems to be where the big risk
is.
His diet and people that work around
chemicals.
There's a lot of people that are out
there that they just took a job because
it's a good job and it pays well,
but you're in like a slow death
sentence.
Absolutely.
That fucking sucks,
man.
That's got to be the weirdest way to
make a living,
to be trapped in a,
in a gig where you're very job itself,
uh,
slowly chew in a way.
Your body while you were doing comedy in
the nineties as well.
And remember going
to clubs on the for the whole weekend
and be full of fucking smoke.
Oh yeah.
I remember.
I remember just leaving gigs.
I just,
it fucking rick.
You couldn't wear the same clothes
twice.
He couldn't had the shower as soon as he
got back home.
And oftentimes he didn't realize it
until you open up your bag,
right?
Yeah.
You clothes,
take your clothes out.
When you got home you're like,
what the fuck?
He just stunk like cigarettes.
But cigarettes,
if you're a waitress,
it's the worst,
like a lot,
directly in the line of fire with them
then.
And you're there all the time.
Like in the days when they used to be
able to smoke in bars.
I bet a lot of chicks got a lot of
waitresses got a cancer from secondhand
smoke.
Yeah.
I just remembered.
And the worst the gig,
the more the smoke for some reason.
It's just crazy.
That wasn't that long ago.
Really wasn't,
wasn't I remember when they banned
smoking.
Must've been around 2000,
maybe 99 maybe at the latest.
Yeah.
The weird improvements that that
happened that are pretty goddamn
significant at the time.
People are protesting.
We willing to smoke in bars.
We knew there was a,
I remember people complaining saying
that pool halls,
we're going to go out of business
because they wouldn't allow people to
smoke in them anymore.
People had to stand outside to smoke.
And then the old days everybody smoked
indoors too.
Fucking weird.
Gross habit planes,
you know fitzsimmons,
right?
Yeah.
Fitzsimmons parents were um,
chainsmokers when he was a kid and they
lived in boston.
So it's the winter and the windows are
closed,
locked down,
and they are smoking in the house chain,
smoking with the kids.
Greg gets asthma.
He's got asthma from this.
They'd be in the car going on a road
trip,
smoking in their car windows.
My friend's father smoked.
They would do that shit in the car.
Wintertime wouldn't roll down the
window.
Fuck.
It's too cold.
Make everybody breathe your smoke.
Is there any habit like that where you
forced the consequences of your habit on
other people?
Maybe alcoholism.
Imagine if you dated someone and they
farted on you so much.
Your clothes smell like farts.
He'd be like,
god jusT keeps farting.
She's always farting on me.
I like that.
We blamed it on her.
Well,
I'm saying if you dated someone,
I mean,
I'm assuming you're not dating any
dudes.
No,
no.
But if you were dating a dude and the
dude just farted all over you,
like you'd come home,
be like,
mike,
we can't fuck anymore.
Every time I take my clothes out of the
bag,
I smell farts.
I bring it home.
People go somebody 40 on you?
Yeah.
Mike was farting all over me and
surprised.
I'm surprised my lady.
It doesn't smell like farts.
I rip on her sleep.
He's addicted to foreign on her leg to.
She doesn't even flinch when you fart on
her.
Don't let her live.
Huh?
Wow.
You just fart on her.
But it not like I'm trying to talk about
it because he come up.
He kind of giggled about it.
So.
Wow.
She's a trooper.
she is a trooper.
Thug life.
Yeah.
that's not good for on people but it.
But it's essentially what people were
doing with
cigarette smokes.
Right?
Which is getting into your clothes and
you were smelling like cigarette smoke.
You were making people smell like what
you were into.
Yeah.
and then whatever disease you were x a
susceptible to.
So are you now you,
it,
it doesn't smell as bad as a fart,
but it's just,
it's as obnoxious.
It's in the neighborhood.
Right.
It's like a hard left from a fart,
but it's still gross.
So.
Yeah.
But it doesn't smell like shit right
now.
A fart is my,
as george carlin said,
shit.
Without the mess,
is that what you're saying?
What's ended on that?
That's the perfect way to end this
thing.
Powerful george carlin from beyond the
grave gets the best line of the show.
Hilarious photo.
Powerful.
Russell peters.
Thank you very much for coming in here.
Dude.
It was phonics.
Joe.
Appreciate it.
And uh,
indian food,
we're going to make it happen,
right?
Definitely the real deal.
Real deal.
OkaY.
Bread,
garlic,
naan bread.
Is that the real deal?
Is that american shit?
But no,
that's north.
North India.
And you need to make that right.
Otherwise it's just,
you're.
Otherwise you're getting the north
american one.
Okay.
You need a special oven for that.
This podcast is over cnx week fUckers.
Well,
we did what we could.